the SCP Foundation is no stranger to
Pure Evil whether it's a reptile that
wants to end all life a sadistic old man
with his own torture Dimension where the
personification of death itself lurking
Beyond a limestone Cavern but what if
there was something even worse out there
the embodiment of chaos and cruelty
existing across multiple realities and
dimensions and what if it was coming for
us this is the Scarlet King believed by
many to be the ultimate Evil behind much
of the trouble the foundation has faced
and some even speculate that fighting
him was the reason the foundation was
created in the first place but what
exactly is the Scarlet King he's known
by many names almost always including
some allusion to the color red and then
a reference to royalty or power
the red Shah the Crimson Khan pte 616
Mendes ex machina the laharaja and of
course
scp-001 to name a few and like many of
the foundation's mysterious enemies
stories about his true nature and
Origins abound and are often
contradictory according to the official
scp-001 files of tufto's proposal
symbology of the Scarlet King has
existed in multiple cultures throughout
history with the King often depicted the
same way as a huge red demonic figure
often wearing a gold crown or other
headdress indicating royalty he shows up
looking similarly within different
cultures mythologies despite existing at
different points in history or them not
having the means to communicate with one
another a number of entities at the SCP
Foundation is familiar with are believed
to be somehow connected to the Scarlet
King including SCP
2317 a wooden door leading to the realm
of a being known as the Devourer who is
expected to escape and cause an
apocalyptic event in the next 30 Years
but really there's no way of knowing
just how many scps are directly
connected to the Scarlet King strangely
the foundation's official file on the
Scarlet King once designated his
containment class as Qatar but that has
since been downgraded to Safe according
to the file any attempt to change this
designation is likely to lead to
horrifying results it is widely known
that the Scarlet King still has
considerable influence over a number of
groups individuals and anomalies in our
universe and if ever he made his way
into our universe it would likely lead
to the irreversible damage of reality
itself so then why save and why are the
o5 council so adamant that it remained
that way getting to the bottom of this
mystery 3 is exactly why we're here
today but to fully grasp the true nature
of the Scarlet King we must first
understand the man whose life and fate
have always been tied to it Dr Robert
Montauk if that name feels oddly
familiar to you it's because of its
association with one of the Scarlet
King's most recent attempts to enter our
reality
scp-231 this SCP often referred to as
the brides of the Scarlet King was
formed of seven women seven by the way
being an extremely significant number
for the king all kidnapped by the most
recent and along line of the king's
devoted Cults known as the children of
the Scarlet King each of these seven
unfortunate women were impregnated with
anomalous Horrors such as the infamous
scp-682 and every time one of these
Horrors were birthed the catastrophe
occurred and the mother died at the time
Dr Montague was a prominent researcher
studying this anomaly it has six
catastrophes had already occurred
pressure was mounting to figure out a
way to prevent the final birth but as he
was working on the issue Dr Montauk was
struck with a personal tragedy the
mysterious disappearance of his
fourteen-year-old brother Jacob in his
fear and anger Montauk believed that
this must have something to do with the
Scarlet King and his disciples wanting
Revenge Montauk proposed an idea so
horrifying that the details were never
made public a procedure known as 110
Montauk to be performed on the final
bride at regular intervals however this
wasn't the end of Dr montauk's fraught
relationship with the Scarlet King it
was just the beginning to give you some
perspective on just how dangerous the
Scarlet King is the SCP Foundation and
the global occult Coalition decided to
put aside their differences and form a
joint effort to Stamp Out the children
of the Scarlet King they were successful
in this Mission and even managed to
capture the children's leader a
mysterious man named Depeche Spivak Dr
Montauk who became the lead researcher
on 231 and 2317 was naturally the first
choice for interviewing dipesh about the
true nature of the children and of the
Scarlet King Dr Montauk could never be
the impartial interviewer that the SCP
Foundation wanted though
the suspicion that the Scarlet king or
the children had something to do with
the loss of his younger brother
still lingered just beneath the surface
like a lot of cult leaders the pesh was
extremely cryptic and his answers to Dr
montauk's questioning he'd already heard
of the doctor from the reputation of the
horrifying Montauk procedure and was
surprised to see him so calm and
courteous in person a few key facts
about the king and his cult were
revealed in the first few rounds of
questioning the children had once worked
with the Serpent's hand before being
excommunicated for their allegiance to
the king and they had stolen sacred
texts from the mystical Wanderers
library to assist in their summoning
rituals Depeche also revealed that the
Scarlet King is bound by Three Laws the
law of blood the law of concrete and the
law of howling Dr Montauk confused and
frustrated by depech's secrecy had to
learn more he found an old Memoir from a
former member of the children of the
Scarlet King Jack Hirsch who had the
ability to invade the minds of people
from the past and experience what they
experienced he recounted a battle
between the Scarlet King and his
followers and a group of time traveling
turkmen Warriors from
scp-3838 Hearst saw both sides of the
battle from the perspective of the
children of the Scarlet King their lord
ruled over them from an immense Fortress
embedded in a volcano from the
perspective of the turkmen the children
were starved and beaten peasants
commanded by the king's voice in The
Roaring howl of the wind Montauk also
found extensive records of summoning
rituals performed by various Scarlet
king-aligned Cults interestingly some of
them Incorporated the use of carved SCP
Foundation symbols what could this mean
Montauk returned again to Depeche who
finally gave him the truth about the law
of blood this is the law of the Scarlet
King it's defined by poverty violence
starvation hate and most of all fear
like surfs in the Middle Ages persecuted
by and subjected to violence from the
Nobles do the children of the Scarlet
King this sense of holy pain and awe is
the only way to live the alternative is
the law of concrete which means the
Modern Age defined by empty safety and
false Comfort buildings easy to access
food Health Care knowledge technology
this is everything that the Scarlet King
despises but the mystery only deepened
as Montauk found files from a former
Foundation operative by the name of
agent dibuvoir Montauk learned that the
Scarlet King didn't seem to appear until
after the foundation was created and in
fact it seemed that the greater interest
the foundation took in The Scarlet King
the more powerful he became how could
this be things were also getting
stranger on a personal level for Dr
Montauk Depeche repeatedly pressed him
about his brother's disappearance and
the Montauk procedure during the
interviews little by little it was
beginning to take its toll the questions
still plagued him what was the law of
howling who or what really is the
Scarlet King how did he come to be
montauk's search was causing him to act
more like the children of the Scarlet
King ranting about the horrors of the
modern world how all of us are living a
lie how the only honest way to live is
suffering under the Dominion of the
Scarlet King this philosophy is summed
up in the words of one cultist named
Arya Denae Cartwright who said we must
learn what it is to die to be enslaved
truly brutally enslaved with no
compassion or compunction from our
masters we must learn what it is to be
taken towards a single purpose to know
and truly understand our lack of agency
we must be beholden to the words of gods
and darkness The Tempest tossed Refuge
of a race of fools we must kill
modernity post modernity with all its
analysis and sneering observation there
is only one rule the rule of chaos for
Humanity for life for the Scarlet King
basically anytime Humanity tries to
exert control over the world the Scarlet
King gets stronger every time they try
to understand or organize or categorize
their world the Scarlet King gets
stronger as Colonial and Imperial Powers
conquered and invaded lands like India
Africa and South America and subjugated
their beliefs under Western ideas the
Scarlet King grew stronger Montauk was
beginning to truly understand the power
of His enemy here and even worse he was
starting to understand his part in it
Montauk slowly being driven mad by the
knowledge he was gaining real lies that
the Scarlet King's greatest enemy the
SCP Foundation was also its greatest
asset every time they tried to
understand the monster to give him some
kind of comprehensible form they only
made him more powerful just in time with
montauk's new revelation a red crack
appeared in the wall of Depeche spivak's
containment cell a portal to the realm
of the Scarlet King foundation staff
found they were unable to enter the cell
and Depeche demanded a final interview
with Montauk with no other options the
foundation relented in their very last
conversation Depeche congratulated
Montauk for finally understanding what
he was dealing with the Scarlet King
dipesh told him is an idea a concept he
is a being given power through the
conflict between the old and the new
this is the law of the howling the
Scarlet King's endless rage at the
direction the world and human entity has
taken the king according to the pesh
hated the foundation's belief that
science and rationality was the true
path to progress the king saw this as
little more than Petty arrogance the
reason montauk's procedure on the final
Bride of the Scarlet King was so
effective was because it wasn't born out
of science it was born out of hate pain
the desire for revenge and in The
Scarlet Kings realm that would be all
there is a must our world and especially
the foundation changed its course the
Scarlet King's rise to absolute power
would be inevitable Montauk is mine
practically gone asked one last question
did the children or the Scarlet king
take his brother Jacob when depesh told
him the answer no and in response
Montauk shot him dead finally bringing
an end to the children of the Scarlet
King in light of his new Revel relations
Montauk bagged the o5 council to change
their ways in order to avoid letting the
Scarlet King break into our reality they
refused saying montauk's ideas were too
radical but they knew they couldn't just
ignore the threat posed by the Scarlet
King they would have to take some steps
and so the o5 Council of the SCP
Foundation the most powerful and
secretive group in the entire world in
order to prevent the most dangerous
threat that Humanity has ever known from
breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world finally did
something they changed the
classification of the Scarlet King from
ketter to safe and made its description
on the official Foundation files
deliberately vague the o5 council thinks
this will be enough to stop the Scarlet
King's power from continuing to grow but
Montauk knew it wasn't enough he had
seen the truth and he couldn't unsee it
while the foundation nation was going on
as normal Montauk grew to despise them
he knew the Scarlet King was coming he
knew that he couldn't be stopped and
that our whole reality was little more
than sitting ducks Dr Robert Montauk is
no longer a researcher for the SCP
Foundation now Dr Robert Montauk chose a
different path he's now a child of the
Scarlet King a devotee of Madness hate
and Chaos you can't beat the Scarlet
king after all and as the old adage goes
if you can't beat him join them it's the
late 90s and an Air Canada flight
experiences severe malfunctions while
traveling from London to Vancouver the
pilots are unable to do anything and the
plane crashes into the woods of Northern
Alberta the crash was devastating only
10 of the nearly 300 people on board are
alive and even though they survived the
initial disaster their battle for life
has only just begun it's late autumn in
Northern Canada and there's no telling
when help will arrive if at all if the
survivors want to make it through the
night they need to find shelter and fast
as they trudge through the freezing
Woods the group finds a path that looks
like it might lead them to civilization
after all if there was a path in the
woods that meant they were probably in a
national park and if they were in a
national park there had to be a ranger
station around somewhere where they
could warm up and call for help they
didn't have many other options so they
followed the path which opened up to a
clearing but instead of finding a ranger
station or Campground they found
something none of them could have
expected it was a pawn but there was
something off about it as they got
closer they saw that this strange Pond
wasn't filled with water but blood the
survivors were horrified that couldn't
really be blood could it it must have
been a weird algae or chemical reaction
but one member of the group a man named
Thomas Dean who had been on his way back
to his hometown of Prince George British
Colombia thought there was something
strangely familiar about this he
remembered being a boy and going to
visit family in Alberta and hearing an
urban legend from the older local kids
according to the stories somewhere out
in the wilderness in the northern part
of the province there was a pond full of
human blood and what made it even worse
was that some said the pond was a
gateway to Hell the SCP Foundation was
also aware of this Legend and had been
trying to pinpoint the exact source of
it for decades prior to the Air Canada
crash they would finally receive
definite confirmation of the blood Pond
when Foundation Personnel intercepted a
radio transmission from a ranger station
located within the Wood Buffalo national
park it was the survivors of the crash
who had managed to make it through the
night and they were about to be escorted
out of the park by Rangers the
foundation mobilized quickly to cordon
off the pond as at the time they were
unsure of what potentially harmful
properties the pond might have had they
set up watch station Epsilon 38 and put
staff on guard to deter travelers from
the area the pond was given the
designation of scp-354 and classed as
Euclid Foundation scientists made a
number of interesting discoveries about
scp-354 when they collected samples for
testing first the pawn was not in fact
full of blood merely an inorganic liquid
that closely resembles blood in color
and consistency second and even Stranger
Than The Red liquid is that the pond
doesn't seem to have any definite Banks
or a bottom instead the liquid in the
pond increases in density as the radius
away from the center increases the
liquid congeals at the edges becoming
more solid and blending into the
surrounding soil it also becomes thicker
as one descends deeper into the pool and
the bottom of the pond has not yet been
reached if it even exists initially the
foundation found no signs of life within
the blood Pond but that would all change
at 203 pm on the day following the
opening of Watch Station Epsilon 38 when
the science team noticed an unusual
level of activity on the Pond's surface
security footage feed showed a shape
rising out of the pond followed by a
deafening shriek after that the feed was
cut and Foundation lost all
communication with watch station Epsilon
38 fearing the worst a mobile task force
was dispatched to the location when they
got there all Personnel at the watch
station had been killed by what could
only be described as a gigantic bat the
task force was able to neutralize the
entity and as soon as they could the
foundation moved in to increase security
around the SCP creating area 354 and
installing a permanent security detail
after this point the pawn started to
regularly spit out a variety of
monstrous entities almost as if it was
reacting to the SCP foundation's
increased security measures after
scp-354-1 the giant bat came
scp-354-2
354-2 was an echidna-like monster the
size of a bear that was virtually
bulletproof but unable to escape area
354. the foundation should neutralize
this anomaly with Napalm
scp-354-3 was a floating black sphere
capable of firing deadly beams of
concentrated energy the area's head
scientists was able to hit it with a
sledgehammer causing the sphere to
malfunction and self-destruct before it
was able to escape the area the
foundation wasn't as lucky with
scp-354-4 this creature was a reptilian
humanoid that stood roughly 15 feet tall
and was unable to be put down with
gunfire this was the first Creature from
the pond to successfully Escape
containment and was only able to be
neutralized when the foundation sent in
Mobile task force omega-7 also known as
Pandora's Box the data on Pond
incursions is partially corrupted so a
complete list of creatures is not
available but some of the other monsters
that came out of the blood Pond include
a killer robot a set of gigantic
tentacles that drag several d-class
Personnel into the pond a pair of
panther-like creatures one made of ice
and the other of magma that ignored
Foundation staff and instead fought each
other other and one seemingly normal
human man who was executed as soon as he
emerged from the pond tests on his body
revealed that he was in fact totally
normal and would have posed no threat
these anomalies came out of the pond at
fairly regular intervals for several
months before the pond went silent for
an unprecedented 22 months the head
scientists at the time noted I suspect
this means one of two things either the
red pool has died or powered down or
whatever the correct term for it is or
is charging up for something big to come
through o5 believes the former is the
most likely explanation and has recalled
30 of our total personnel and cut 25
percent of our funding while I can only
hope that they are correct if the latter
situation is true we're soon to face
some terrible monstrosity and we won't
have anywhere near the force necessary
to deal with it I worry for all of our
safety his words would prove eerily
prophetic following the events of
exploratory Mission 354 Alpha the
foundation's research and development
team built a specialized craft to
explore the pond because of the strange
properties of the Pond's density the
craft was essentially made to be both a
submarine for parts of the pond where
the contents were liquid and a drill for
when the liquid congealed into a
semi-solid towards the bottom the
exploration team consisted of agent
Swanson agent turquoise agent 86 Dr J
McArthur Chris Simmons Leroy Tucker and
a pilot named Mark with the team
assembled the ship was sent down into
the pond nothing eventful happened for
the first two days of the mission but at
4 30 a.m on the third day gravity
suddenly reversed for the crew of the
ship this seemed to indicate that they
were approaching the halfway point
though what would be on the other side
nobody could say on the fourth day the
ship surfaced proving definitely that
the pond was in fact some sort of portal
the crew looked out of the portholes to
see the darkness of night above them
while sensors outside the ship detected
nothing harmful in the atmosphere around
them the crew were wary of exiting the
craft the other side of the pond was
nothing like the world the crew knew for
one thing the night lasted for 28 hours
before Don came and when the Sun finally
Rose it was much larger and redder than
the Earth's sun under the light of the
strange red star the crew could see that
the pond on this side was massive
compared to what they've come into more
like a large lake surrounding the lake
was sand and rocks that were covered in
a kind of moss that disappeared under
sunlight and regrew during the night the
team left the ship and started to
explore during their time in This
Strange World they found that the day
lasted just a few hours shorter than the
night meaning that whatever Planet they
were on had a roughly 43 hour long
rotation as opposed to our own planets
24. the team found a number of anomalous
elements on their expedition including
razor sharp grass that can puncture skin
in streams of liquid carbon dioxide they
heard some loud Roars in the distance
once or twice but other than that the
planet was eerily silent with seemingly
no animal life and not even
when it rained the soil remained dry and
based on that the scientists theorized
the plants in this world were more
efficient at absorbing moisture on the
25th day the team ran into a huge metal
wall that appeared to be artificially
constructed luckily Leroy Tucker a quick
thinking researcher was able to rig a
blowtorch from camping supplies and melt
a hole through the metal on the other
side there was finally wind and odd
black grass that's the extent of what is
known about the other side of the wall
because the Expedition logs are heavily
corrupted after that point but we know
that whatever was in there wasn't good
because the team never returned
strangely there's no record of any names
mentioned in the ship's log almost as if
being killed on the other side
completely erased them from history no
other Expeditions into the pond were
launched after that on an undisclosed
day a year following the discovery of
the blood Pond and construction of area
354. the site was completely evacuated
and power was cut to the area mobile
task force data 12 was dispatched to
investigate the cause of the evacuation
but before contact could be established
the area's on-site nuclear warhead was
detonated completely destroying the site
MTF Theta 12 was then attacked by a
convoy made up of d-class and other
low-ranking staff who had evacuated area
354. it was apparent that there had been
some kind of mutiny within the site and
that a dissolution of the chain of
command had led to its evacuation and
destruction the Convoy totally
annihilated MTF theta-12 and no further
contact with the former Personnel of
area 354 has been made since following
the site's detonation a new site was
constructed called simply the red pool
containment site unlike the previous
facility which focused on research and
neutralization the new site is entirely
concerned with containment the shift and
directive came as a response to the
Pond's apparent reactive nature each
creature that emerged from the pond
seemed to be in retaliation to the
foundation's actions and it was
theorized by some that the Mutiny at
area 354 was triggered by some kind of
psychic attack from the pond itself an
interview in the SCP file on 354 reveals
that there was one more disastrous
attempt to control and understand the
blood Pond according to an interview
with a foundation agent the head doctor
proposed a scheme to drain the blood
Pond using a system of pumps and hoses
all non-essential Personnel were
evacuated in case of emergency leaving
only the pump technicians d-class
personnel and a few agents for security
however as soon as the pump was
scheduled to be turned on everyone at
the site experienced a mass dissociative
episode the agent described the feeling
they all experienced as like being in a
dream and suddenly realizing that you're
asleep he said everything stopped being
real it was like we had to Escape right
now when asked what happened when the
pump was turned on he simply explained
that it wouldn't let them this interview
confirmed the theory that the pond is
not only capable of releasing monsters
out into our world but also that it's
capable of powerful but much more subtle
psychological attacks this suggests a
chilling possibility that the pond isn't
just blindly reacting to being attacked
but it's fully sentient and the actions
of the SCP Foundation have only served
to annoy it and worst studies of the
ponds banks have proved evidence that
the area of congealed liquid around the
perimeter of the pond has been steadily
expanding that's right the pond is
getting bigger the last thing the
foundation agent stationed at the site
said before being dragged out of the
interview and sedated was it gets bigger
and stronger every day and now we've
made it Angry a swarm of bloodthirsty
entities Waits outside the protective
boundary that surrounds the solar system
they surge through the vacuum of space
looking for vulnerabilities in the force
field that protects us from their
destructive Powers the creatures ran
themselves against the barrier again and
again trying to break through upon
impact the force field shimmers a golden
color and displays a series of
thematurgical symbols
but it holds suddenly something flies
through the protective shield from
inside the solar system it leaves a hole
two creatures enter our solar system
before the shield closes this may be the
end for Humanity the sixth overseer sits
at a computer terminal massaging the
bridge of his nose he is just logged
into the foundation database to gather
information on an anomaly whose
intentions are still unknown the o5
council wants him to vote on an extreme
measure but he requires more information
first there is something coming he can
feel it and he thinks it has something
to do with
scp-1548 05-6 straightens his back and
sits up in his chair he logs back into
the foundation database and brings up
the entry for
scp-1548 he knows that this SCP has been
connected to some odd occurrences
recently but what are its true
intentions his scp-1548 trying to help
save the universe or is it a malicious
entity hell-bent on destroying it 05-6
must find out he Scrolls through the
first few entries
scp-1548 itself is a series of solar
phenomena that occur at the South Pole
of the Sun during these events the sun's
plasma morphs into different
pharmaturgical symbols each symbol is
tens of thousands of miles across the
symbols themselves have not all been
classified by the foundation yet but
there are three that have been observed
multiple times the first is an unnamed
symbol that when inscribed on a
telescopic device by a person with
thamaturgical abilities can identify
psionic entities with malicious intents
the second symbol is known as the
kalfastian aisle which when displayed on
a material strengthens it immensely and
gives it the ability to absorb kinetic
and electromagnetic energy the final
symbol is the 12 holy owls of serenthium
when this symbol is affixed to an object
any entity T that is killed by it will
immediately annihilate and take
everything in its radius with it 05-6
jots a note on the pad of paper sitting
on his desk he has seen some of these
symbols before they are connected to the
art ofan mythology the practitioners of
this religion are known as the Church of
the second high top and are a mix of
human and alien entities whose main
purpose is to Aid the guardian deity of
the universe rakmuliosen in combating
any threat that may try to wipe out this
existence there must be a connection
between the Church of the second high
top and
scp-1548-05-6 thinks he Scrolls back
through the scp-1548 file to the entry
logged on May 17 1983 the first time an
event connected to
scp-1548 was recorded a pro picked up
the manifestation of thymaturgic symbols
on the South Pole of the sun it was odd
but nothing other than the manifestation
of the symbols seemed to occur this
event was recorded as extra-normal
events 9008 and logged into the SCP
database the event was all but forgotten
until December 23 2016 when the activity
of
scp-1548 really began to pick up on that
day
scp-1548 began manifesting protection
symbols in Rapid succession over the
next few months a dense cloud of ionized
gas formed around the solar system this
ionized wall of radiation surrounded the
heliopause the boundary where the sun's
radiation gives way to the vacuum of
space over time this Cloud became
thicker until no light from outside of
the solar system could enter Foundation
censorship protocols were quickly used
to disseminate false data suggesting
that the solar system was passing
through a dense cloud of cosmic dust and
that was what was altering the night sky
and causing the Stars to disappear but
as 05-6 continues to scan the files he
knows what the true cause of this
phenomenon is it must be scp-1548 but
why is the anomaly trying to protect us
from something outside of our solar
system or is it trying to trap Humanity
within with no means of Escape 05-6
stands up and stretches huh that's
enough for today he says out loud to the
empty room he walks towards the door and
reaches for the handle all of a sudden
Sirens start going off and red lights
begin to flash 05-6 spins around and
runs back to the computer terminal an
emergency alert begins coming through
the Falcon Lite 5 rocket that launched
earlier in the day to bring supplies to
the International Space Station has
spontaneously lost 50 percent of its
mass mid-flight 05-6 frantically begins
typing he brings up videos from
surveillance satellites the overseer
watches in horror as pieces of debris
and bodies of the crew flow through the
Silence of space the rocket looks like
it has been cut directly down the middle
and half of the structure has vanished
from existence what is happening
suddenly another alert comes in all
communication has been lost with the
International Space Station without
warning the space station begins
broadcasting a series of Cognito hazards
05-6 quickly changes the channel to stop
the signal from transmitting through his
computer reports start coming in from
around the world that anyone who
continued listening to the Cognito
Hazard signals began entering trances
then their brain completely evaporated
from their skulls there is a surge of
thermaturgic particles in orbit around
the Earth 05-6 traces the particles back
to their Source they came from
scp-1548 the signal from the ISS stops
abruptly the entire space station
changes course it is on a trajectory to
re-enter the Earth's atmosphere the
friction and heat will rip the space
station apart 05-6 can't believe what is
happening it seems as if scp-1548 helped
Humanity in a way by stopping the
signals from the ISS but how can he be
sure that scp-1548 wasn't responsible
for the Cognito hazards in the first
place he needs more information 05-7
searches for answers as more anomalies
connected to scp-1548 start occurring
around the world during a political
demonstration in Berlin a thermaturgic
way opens up that leads to a pocket
Dimension soon after the appearance of
the portal Koro Arch priest pharah
attenus the leader of the Church of the
second high top makes an announcement he
claims that the way leads to a shelter
which will protect people from the
coming Doom of the universe the people
in the area along with the members of
the Church of the second high top make
their way into the portal two undercover
Foundation agents follow the group after
everyone has entered the way immediately
closes and there is no further contact
what does the church of the second high
top know that we don't 05-6 wonders he
continues monitoring the situation and
looking for answers suddenly a message
comes through all Foundation channels it
is coming from the Sun it is not
scp-1548 instead it is
scp-179 the human eye permanently in
space near the sun 179 sends out one
clear word in its signal defend who was
scp-179 talking to 05-6 thinks what
needs to be defended is it Humanity our
solar system the universe another alarm
begins to go off what now 05-6 screams
he brings up the alert the screen
flashes to the Moon 05-6 focuses in on
where the alert is coming from it is a
foundation Base called area 32 what
remains left of the base is reporting
that
scp-2821 suddenly expanded in size
formed a wormhole that led to another
region of the universe and then vanished
through it taking 38 Foundation members
and 10 anomalies with it Sirens continue
to go off distress signals are being
picked up on every channel it seems as
if the world is coming to an end and
everything that is happening is somehow
connected to
scp-1548 as static filled transmission
begins coming in from scp-3417 the words
are Urgent all are toughens here all our
cousins must listen now the stars are
lost static breaks up the transmission
for a few moments before it resumes ago
the first Invasion occurred the gods
were unprepared never comprehending the
fragility of the universe after its
creation the worlds must fight the
transmission cuts off everything goes
silent a pulsating SCP icon appears on
the screen of 05-6's computer it is the
part of the puzzle he has been waiting
for in 1999 the o5 council unanimously
voted to launch a mission called serif 1
to explore beyond the heliosphere and
the mission's true purpose was to
explore the plausibility of
extraterrestrial SCP objects in Space
the message that 05-6 just received is
from serif 1. it is relaying information
back to Earth the video shows the
barrier of ionized radiation that
scp-1548 had created glowing orange at
the border of the heliopause the
radioactive wall seems to be made up of
complex geometric patterns around 6 000
miles across serif1 accelerates towards
the barrier it smashes through the
protective shell the probe has entered
Interstellar space 05-6 knows that
everything he is seeing is on a delay as
the information being sent back by
serif1 needs to travel vast distances
and it takes significant time for
signals to reach Earth after passing
through the ionized barrier the
connection to serif 1 is lost over the
next few days 05-6 tries to link the
anomalies happening in the solar system
to scp-1548 the foundation still hasn't
concluded that 1548 is harmful or trying
to protect the solar system in some way
then a message comes in from serif1 it
is briefly regained communication with
the foundation most of the probe's
instruments have been destroyed but its
rear-facing camera is still broadcasting
05-6 pulls up the feed he stares at the
screen in horror as the images unfold
before him the camera captures swarms of
unknown entities surrounding the
heliopause the bodies of the entities
are asymmetrical with countless
appendages and unknown structures
jutting out from their cores they seem
to range in size from 10 kilometers to
10 000 kilometers across although some
seem so large that their size can only
be hypothesized the Swarms crash into
the protective barrier that scp-1548 has
created around the solar system each
time part of the swarm Rams the barrier
thousands of thalmaturgic symbols and
solar flares appear at the point of
impact two entities that are later
classified as 1548 Omega 1 and 1548
omega-2 are captured entering the solar
system by serif ones camera video from
serif 1 shows that as the probe exited
through the protective barrier it
created a hole that remained open for a
few moments during the time that the
shield of ionized radiation was
vulnerable
1548-omega-1 and
1548-omega-2 entered through it they are
now inside the solar system
scp-1548 launches countermeasures in the
form of glowing red sigils that create
shock waves to slow down omega-1 and
omega-2
omega-1 is shaped like an EO with five
contorted arms radiating from its body
and a mouth made of impossible geometric
shapes omega-2 has a tetrahedral
structure that leaves a trail of black
rocks in its wake as the two entities
move towards the sun
scp-1548 becomes more active it closes
the hole in the barrier before any other
creatures of the Swarm can enter and
then launches hundreds of concentrated
blasts of thalmic energy at omega-2 the
flares vaporize the entity in seconds
the last thing the video feed of Seraph
Dash 1 captures before it cuts out is
omega-1 disappearing from view as it
creeps towards the center of the solar
system it has escaped the protective
measures of
scp-1548 after the o5 council reviews
the footage they decide to deploy the
scps Cortana to intercept omega-1 the
orbital vessel is fully equipped with
experimental anomalous weapons and
propulsion systems the council is sure
that the Cortana will be able to destroy
omega-1 data coming in from other
satellites indicate that omega-1 has
destroyed Pluto another Kuiper Belt
objects it is slowly making its way to
the center of the solar system
annihilating everything in its path the
Cortana intercepts omega-1 near Jupiter
and engages the creature after 10
minutes of battling communication with
the ship is lost probes in the area
capture footage of the Cortana and
omega-1 in mid-battle when they are
suddenly surrounded by a black substance
and both vanish from light 05-6 and the
other council members watch in
anticipation unsure of what has just
happened then the black substance
dissipates the scps Cortana sits
Motionless In Space the entity is
nowhere to be seen a cheer erupts from
the overseers and Foundation members in
the room it seems the entity has been
defeated then without warning the
Cortana accelerates rapidly it is on a
collision course with Mars as the ship
hurdles past one of the probes in the
asteroid belt the foundation members see
an organic Mass resembling that of
omega-1 attached to the hull of the ship
the overseer Council watches in horror
as the scps Cortana smashes into the red
planet leaving a crater 215 miles wide
the energy released from the impact
instantly ionizes the thin atmosphere of
Mars causing the surface to turn into
molten rock from the epicenter of the
impact crater a black organic Mass
begins to crawl across the planet the
overseers are frozen in fear but
scp-1548 immediately deals with the
entity that is devouring the surface of
Mars from the Sun comes the largest
scp-1548 instance ever recorded a solar
flare is jettisoned towards Mars the
impact causes a fusion reaction so
intense that for a moment Mars shines as
brightly as the sun the planet explodes
its debris is cast across the solar
system over time it will create a second
asteroid belt in the orbit that Mars
once inhabited the overseer council is
now convinced that the threat has been
dealt with
scp-1548 is holding the Swarm at Bay
outside of the solar system at least for
the moment 05-6 returns to his office he
brings up the file on
scp-1548 he is still unsure of this
scp's true intentions it seems to be
protecting Humanity but why 05-6 sits
back in his chair and Scrolls to the end
of the file all there is an update to
the file by 05-3 something that wasn't
there before
05-6 opens the new entry and reads the
caption all that's left of our infinite
ever expanding Universe 05-6 Scrolls
down the images of picture taken by
serif1 before contact was lost forever
it is a picture of All That Remains of
the universe there are two dots of light
and nothing else but Blackness the Swarm
has destroyed everything in the universe
except for those two far away stars and
our own solar system which was protected
by
scp-1548 but how long can it hold out
against a universe destroying Force only
time will tell a man is sitting in a
chair inside a containment cell at the
SCP Foundation the man is dressed
normally and he isn't trying to escape
or attack the researchers who are
observing him the only thing that makes
this man different from you or I is that
he ages right in in front of us going
from a teenager to an old man in a
matter of minutes at first glance
scp-1007 looks very normal just a corpse
lying in a standard coffin well the
corpse of an old man in a coffin being
kept locked up in a containment chamber
is normal when compared to some of the
other strange anomalies that are found
in the SCP foundation's archives inside
the coffin with
scp-1007 is a small Metal Key and this
is quite literally the key to seeing
what makes this anomaly so special on
scp-1007's back between his shoulder
blades is a small Keyhole x-ray scans of
1007 have shown that the keyhole is just
an empty socket it's unconnected to
anything there's no internal Clockwork
mechanisms or other Machinery that
should be able to be activated by a key
when the metal key that is kept in
scp-1007's coffin classified as
scp-1007-1 is inserted into the keyhole
on one zero zero sevens back in turn
something truly incredible happens as
the key is turned
scp-1007 undergoes a change unlike
anything the SCP Foundation has seen
before with each turn of the key the
subject's physical age is reversed by
one full year Foundation researchers are
able to watch 1007 age in Reverse in
real time even any Decay that had set in
on the corpse is completely reversed and
disappears as the key is wound in 1007
gets younger and younger as the key is
turned 1007 will continue to DH
physically compacting and shrinking down
until it appears to have the form of a
newborn human child it's unknown where
the physical mass of 1007's body goes to
since this should defy the laws of
physics but those laws we assume to be a
Bedrock of our universe's reality are
often more of a suggestion when it comes
to anomalies the SCP Foundation deals
with once
scp-1007 reaches the newborn baby stage
it will suddenly reactivate coming to
life immediately regardless of how long
it has been dead and lying in its coffin
once 1007 is brought back to life he
will go through the entire human life
cycle within a 75 minute period
experiencing what looks to be
approximately one year of normal human
growth and development for every minute
that passes that means that in the
course of about 16 minutes researchers
will see
scp-1007 change from a crying infant to
a fully grown teenager as you can
imagine the subject has reported feeling
excruciating pain during these first few
minutes as his bones rapidly lengthen
and expand and his muscles develop and
change shape dramatically
scp-1007 is able to watch with his young
eyes as his bones move and set
themselves into place lengthening and
widening in seconds during growth spurts
that normally take months or years after
about five minutes provided his his legs
have grown to the same length at the
same time he's usually able to prop
himself up and stand at around 10
minutes the pain really starts the bones
crack and ache as they grow at their
fastest for the whole cycle hair will
also grow on his face and body and he
can't help but feel some amount of Shame
and embarrassment at what's happening to
him in front of the foundation
researchers who are taking copious notes
by 20 minutes he can hardly think due to
the pain at this point he usually lies
down and curls into a ball whispering to
himself that it will all be over soon
that the pain won't last forever after
another 10 minutes he's right the pain
is almost stopped completely by the
30-minute mark But now as wrinkles and
stretch marks start to set in a
different kind of pain reveals itself as
scp-1007 realizes that he must watch
himself die 40 minutes in and he starts
to reflect on his past the life he was
forced to lead as a kind of Sideshow
freak more on that later though the
physical Decay happens faster now warts
and moles and other marks of age
appearing on his skin after 50 minutes
he is aware that over half of his life
has passed and he's reaching the end his
hair starts to fall out as do his teeth
which he's never actually been able to
use as he's never tasted food as the
60-minute mark comes and goes he begins
to feel grateful for the coming end with
the escape from Pain and the rest it
would bring his body has become very
wrinkled by this point and is covered
with age spots his eyes begin to Cloud
severely limiting his ability to see and
his hearing gets weaker and weaker until
he can't comprehend anything the
researchers say at 75 minutes it's all
over
scp-1007's body expires and he dies once
again he will remain as a corpse until
the metal key is inserted into his back
and the whole process starts once again
just as there appears to be no
explanation for where the mass of
scp-1007's body goes as the key is wound
during the reversal process so too is
there no explanation for where the
energy needed for his rapid growth comes
from this process should violate the
first law of thermodynamics and
Foundation researchers are very curious
about the underlying process the one
constant that remains on
scp-1007's body is a small tattoo on his
right calf where the words Mr life and
Mr death from Little misters by Dr
wondertainment appear
this matches up with entry number 11 on
document
scp-909 which lists a total of 20 little
misters
scp-1007 was recovered by task force Tau
6 during a raid on a mansion in
California along with several other
anomalous creatures and objects
the owner of the Mansion claimed that he
acquired
scp-1007 at an auction hosted by
Marshall Carter and dark Limited
Marshall Carter and dark limited is a
club based in London England that is
famed for collecting and selling what it
would describe as rare and obscure
objects unfortunately this often
includes various anomalies that should
be under the care of the SCP Foundation
and the club's mission to provide its
members with exclusive expensive and
rare experiences means that they're
often in conflict with the foundation
and they have even been responsible for
several containment breaches
Marshall Carter and dark limited
continues to be a very secretive
organization and the name of the
director and a list of its members have
so far been very difficult to obtain at
the auction they hosted where scp-1007
was offered for sale there were
apparently along with Mr life and death
at least four other misters for sale
though the identity of the other buyers
and which little misters they may have
purchased is still under investigation
the fact that
scp-1007 has the name Mr life and Mr
death seems to imply that he may have
originally been part of a set though
this counterpart little Mister has yet
to be recovered or even identified in
interviews with
scp-1007 he has given his own personal
theory that he embodies both names and
the designation is a reference to the
way he alternates between life and death
however the possibility Still Remains
though that he may have a twin of sorts
and the foundation continues to
investigate its possible identity and
location
scp-1007's brief 75-minute life followed
by a death that lasts until he is
rewound by a special key means that he
is easily contained and has been
classified as safe he is only to be
activated during routine testing and
After experiencing death he is to be
placed back into his coffin along with
the key in keeping with current
regulations for all anomalies that have
been designated as misters
scp-1007 is to be contained in Hall 8 of
site 13 for additional observation and
study every neighborhood has a house
like it you can probably picture it that
old decrepit building on the very end of
the street it was there when you moved
in and it'll still be there when you
move out all sorts of salicious rumors
spread about houses like this it's a
drug lab it's a hideout for fugitives
it's haunted but these are all just
stories right some of these houses
contain real nightmares though
nightmares like
scp-136 there's a grain of Truth in
every story and even lies can reveal
certain facts about their tellers that's
why the SCP Foundation takes reports of
so-called neighborhood haunted houses
seriously and performs regular checks on
such buildings to see if any of them are
actually the real deal children can have
wild imaginations but when children
living on the same street years apart
hard with no reason to have been in
contact with one another I'll start
reporting an eerily similar Apparition
in that creepy old house and when the
stories go beyond just getting freaked
out and delve into truly life-altering
traumatic paralytic Terror then the
foundation really can't afford not to
look into it one otherwise quiet morning
in a sleepy American town a convoy of
fumigation and asbestos removal trucks
pulled in surrounding that creepy Old
House at the End of the Street residents
were probably thinking it's about time
someone tore that old death trap down as
people in protective suits spilled into
the building these were of course
Foundation field agents who would
perform a routine sweep around every
room and fully catalog the place it
looked like a pretty typical abandoned
house peeling wallpaper Dusty rotten
furniture all the trash and Rubble that
seems to appear in the absence of human
life the full sweep took little more
than an hour but towards the end of the
observation period agent Sims a field
agent posted in the former child's
bedroom began acting strangely he posed
a question over the team's shared radio
frequency hey can anyone else hear that
laughter confused the other people on
the team responded that no they could
not hear any laughter a few other agents
came to check on the room but they
didn't hear any laughter in there either
even though agent Sims appeared visibly
uncomfortable there was no identifiable
source for this discomfort the other
agents left him so they could continue
investigating the rest of the house
other than one agent's fraying nerves
there didn't appear to actually be
anything anomalous about the house then
agent Sims screamed and jumped out of
the Second Story window of the house
sailing down towards the ground and
fracturing his spine on impact what
could have made him do that we're
talking about an SCP Foundation field
agent here a highly trained individual
hand-picked by the foundation to observe
and track terrifying and and potentially
deadly anomalies out in the field what
could he possibly have seen in that
decrepit old house that would lead him
to believe leaping to his death was a
preferable alternative to facing it this
was a question that the foundation
absolutely had to get an answer to they
intensified their search on the child's
bedroom as the body of agent Sims was
carted away that's when they found the
object that they would later deem as
scp-136-1 a little rag doll made of old
cloth the kind of thing you could easily
imagine getting carted around by some
ragamuffin child at the turn of the last
century this was the only object of
interest in the entire room so it was
tagged bagged and taken back to the
nearest Foundation containment facility
for further testing they had no idea
what they were about to unleash when the
doll was first brought into its
containment chamber one particular
scientist on the research team Dr Myers
a headstrong young researcher freshly
farmed from a prestigious University
took a morbid interest in the doll
something about it even in the absence
of readily apparent anomalous effects
made her feel oddly uncomfortable the
doll seemed to carry a vague Aura of
Doom was this what made agent Sims act
the way he had or was this only the
beginning a d-class was brought in for
the first wave of testing the
unfortunate former arsonist was forced
to Simply stand around in the room with
a doll and wait until something
interesting happened and for 20 minutes
no anomalous activity was reported then
the d-class began frantically looking
around the room like a frightened animal
Dr Myers who had been observing the test
radioed in and asked what was happening
it's this laughter this weird freaky
laughter like some crazy lady is in here
I can't see her though can any of you
see her can any of you hear that they
couldn't see or hear anything according
to all their monitors it was just a
lonely d-class standing around in an
otherwise empty room with nothing but a
ragdoll five minutes after the d-class
reported hearing the Eerie laughter he
collapsed to the ground shrieking like a
maniac and crawling away from something
he could not see he was emitting the
desperate screams of a man who truly
believed something was about to take his
life but nothing was there he backed
into the corner of the room jibbering
incoherently and scratching desperately
at the wall until his fingernails were
ripping off leaving bloody traces behind
in the end a pair of guards entered the
chamber and had to drag him out the
d-class had urinated in fear and seemed
to have temporarily lost the use of his
legs from sheer Panic he was out of
commission for several hours afterwards
breaking into on and off screaming fits
whenever someone approached him upon
reviewing the footage of the experiment
Dr Myers noticed something strange the
moment that the d-class had begun
screaming the doll had disappeared from
the room it only rematerialized in its
previous position when the d-class was
finally dragged from the room eventually
the d-class became Lucid enough to be
properly interviewed about his
experience he said that after first
hearing the laughter a sense of
overpowering dread had begun building
within him five minutes later that was
when the entity later dubbed
scp-136-2 first appeared the vision that
appeared to him could generously be
described as human but it was a little
too tall to really qualify the monster
appeared to be female but like a
freakish Carnival House of Mirror's
exaggeration of what one thinks of being
female long flowing hair large breasts
and a Barbie doll thin waist she looked
like the nightmarish doodle of a
hormonal teen boy come to life with a
face Twisted into a rictus grim
somewhere between arousal and Agony
showing way too many teeth the creature
was nude and posed provocatively but it
was anything but appealing the d-class
reported that just seeing it was the
most frightening experience of his life
and then it's started moving it was
slowly floating through the air towards
him like a vengeful ghost that painful
smile getting wider as it drew closer to
him the d-class could only describe the
whole experience as feeling like death
itself was coming towards him when the
creature was finally looming over him as
he cowered in the corner it opened its
tooth line jaws and let out a long
piercing shriek before disappearing in
the following weeks the d-class was kept
for testing he experienced severe night
terrors every single night afterwards
all of them related to scp-136 further
Tess looked into the doll itself but
there didn't seem to be anything
anomalous about its construction it
appeared to be made from the kind of
plain non-anomalous materials you'd
expect from any doll of this variety
though occasionally the exact materials
would change even between observers in
addition to the most common cloth
variety Witnesses have reported the doll
being made of clay wood and metal with
10 viewing the doll as male with the
rest all agreeing that the doll is
female the foundation conducted a
battery of tests on the doll just to
make sure that the results were largely
consistent across all subjects over 25
subjects were tested on scp-136 all
reporting roughly the same results
laughter after 20 minutes of observation
a few minutes of silence and then
according to subject testimonials the
appearance of the same grinning naked
Apparition inducing a state of truly
Primal Terror and its victims
interestingly not all the subjects were
d-classes some were volunteering
scientists who were aware of the
potential effects but let their morbid
curiosity get the better of them
thinking they would be prepared to face
whatever terrifying vision would
manifest from the doll but in every case
they were reduced to the same screaming
traumatized wrecks but when a foundation
researcher named Dr Simon the 25th
subject of the scp-136 experiments
volunteered for testing thing took an
even more horrifying turn during the
testing period Dr Simon had the unusual
experience of not actually seeing the
scp-136-2 entity after being told how
terrifying it was by co-workers he was a
little disappointed that he didn't get
to share their fears later that day he
went to get himself a warm cup of coffee
from the site's employee break room his
co-workers became concerned when his
coffee mug dropped to the ground and
shattered as Dr Simon pointed into a
nearby empty hallway and began screaming
he claimed that he could see her
floating down the hallway towards him
her face Twisted into that menacing grin
as none of the other scientists could
see what Simon was seeing they
surrounded him and attempted to calm him
assuming that he was perhaps the victim
of some kind of sudden psychotic break
but minutes later every scientist in the
break room collapsed and fell
unconscious not long after they all
began to wake up except Dr Simon he had
fallen into a coma and died while still
on life support three days later it was
the first report of scp-136 causing a
death since agent Sims unfortunate fall
Dr Myers immediately requested that
scp-136 be reclassified from Euclid to
ketter class so more resources could be
allotted for its containment
Administration denied any changes to the
containment procedures of scp-136
frustrating Dr Myers but little did she
know that it was because site
administration had ulterior motives for
scp-136 no matter who they were whether
they were the hardened killers of
d-class the trained soldiers of the
foundation field agent Corps or jaded
scientists who had seen any number of
Horrors each week as part of their
normal jobs
scp-136 had the unique ability to reduce
its victims to terrifying wrecks in a
move that feels decidedly more in line
with the chaos Insurgency site
administration had started using scp-136
to assist in enhanced interrogation with
detained people of Interest even the
toughest nuts to crack soon became very
talkative after the appearance of
scp-136-2 traumatized them for Life
essentially the administrators were
making a kind of deal with the devil
allowing scp-136 more free reign in
exchange for them Gathering valuable
Intel from these victims but as always
the problem with making deals with the
Devil is that the devil is always going
to collect his Dew in the end Dr Meyer's
warnings would continue to fall upon
deaf ears though even as the creature's
power seem to grow tests on d-class
continued with the entity traumatizing a
whole group at once during one of these
experiments however when Dr Myers
herself along with a few agents entered
the testing chamber to drag out their
twitching bodies they all fell
unconscious when Dr Myers woke back up
three of the d-classes had fallen into
Comas like Dr Simon and died shortly
after Dr Myers played with the
administration to terminate the doll but
her requests were denied it was proving
to be too valuable in its various
interrogations and besides nobody was
sure if the doll could even be
terminated whenever it was damaged it
simply disappeared and reappeared within
a one meter radius the only thing that
hadn't been tried was full vaporization
which Dr Meyer's superiors refused to
sign off on
scp-136 was here to stay unfortunately
the same could not be said for Dr Myers
herself after one more unfortunate
testing incident where d-class
disappeared entirely in what seemed to
be clear evidence of scp-136's Growing
Power Dr Myers implored site
Administration to reclassify the anomaly
and slate it for termination it was
getting more powerful more unstable and
more dangerous but rather than terminate
the anomalous Ragdoll in the end all
they did was remove Dr Myers from the
scp-130 6 case with her gone there was
one less thing for them to worry about
as they gave more and more victims to
scp-136 using its dark powers to torture
detained people of Interest into telling
them everything they wanted to know but
with the entity seeming to grow more
powerful with every victim it seems very
likely that Dr Meyer's worst fears will
come true and one day those controlling
the terrifying anomaly will find that
they're the ones hearing a strange evil
laughter coming from nowhere at all
imagine this it's summer vacation and
you're a kid you and your friends are
playing in the woods near your
neighborhood just like you've been doing
most days during the break from school
one day you spot a tree house it's not
that high off the ground and it's very
Simply Built from leaves grass and
scraps of wood you and your friends are
curious so you decide to check it out
upon investigation you find a kid in
there he says his name is Billy and this
is his tree house you don't recognize
him from school but you figure he just
must be new in town he asks if he can
join your group and wanting to be nice
to the new kid you tell him okay you
spend the rest of the day playing with
him games like hide and seek tag and Red
Rover until it's time for everyone to go
home for dinner strangely Billy doesn't
seem to leave he just stays in his tree
house for the rest of the week playing
with Billy in his Treehouse become a
regular fixture of your daily routine
but oddly enough he never comes to hang
out at any of your houses and you never
seem to see him anywhere else but in the
woods one day however he decides to
invite one of your friends Amy to hang
out with him at the tree house alone you
think nothing of it but after that point
you never see Billy again it's a couple
of weeks before you and your friends see
Amy again and when you do she appears
off somehow she seems to be spending a
lot of time in that tree house Billy
disappear but you and Amy and the rest
of the kids keep meeting up to play
together in the woods one day Amy pulls
you aside she wants you to come meet
with her tomorrow at the tree house
alone this is typically how an scp-974
infestation begins with a mysterious new
kid inviting a group of friends to hang
out in this crudely made tree house but
as you might have guessed this kid isn't
a kid he's
scp-974 a carnivorous monster that only
looks like a human child it can live on
small woodland animals but its preferred
prey is kids between the ages of 6 and
12 taking the phrase you are what you
eat to the next level The Entity will
install itself in an area with a
sufficient amount of trees in proximity
to a decent population of children who
will then construct a crude tree house
to serve as its nest and begin
befriending groups of between two and
five children the creature will engage
in normal outdoor games and allow its
new friends to come and go as they
please building the trust of its
Newfound Playmates but then after about
a week it will select its victim
scp-974 will single out one member of
the group and invite them to the tree
house alone whether they accept or deny
the invitation is irrelevant because
this is the point where scp-974 will
strike subduing and then devouring that
child after doing so the creature will
disappear from the area going into a
state of hibernation for roughly 12 days
during that time it goes through a
period of metamorphosis transforming
from whoever it looked like before into
an exact likeness of the child it just
consumed
scp-974 will continue this cycle of
selecting and catching prey until there
are no children left in the surrounding
area while it's initially friendly to
children
scp-974 has an intense fear of any older
human being
the mere presence of a person older than
13 is enough to trigger the creature's
fight or flight response and it will run
away if it sees any adults coming when
running isn't an option
scp-974 will resort to violence to
defend itself despite its looks
scp-974 is much stronger faster and more
resistant to damage than a child and it
has been known to completely rip adults
apart in situations where it felt
threatened and cornered
scp-974 does not appear to be affected
by bullets or striking weapons and the
only reliable way to put down an instant
seems to be with fire when infestations
are discovered in the wild the normal
SCP Foundation protocol is to attempt to
capture the creature but if deadly force
is required agents Will Set Fire to the
creature's nest and a portion of the
surrounding area until it has been
confirmed dead before covering up the
destruction as the result of a regular
forest fire the SCP Foundation was able
to capture one instant of scp-974 and
place it in containment hoping that
having one in captivity would provide
insight into the creature's Origins it
was placed in a lightly wooded enclosure
at Zoological Reserve site 16 where it
immediately started constructing
multiple Tree House nests from the plant
life it found initially the containment
of scp-974 involved offering the
creature live Human prey once every
three months a group of four children
would be brought in in accordance with
protocol 12 the children would be given
room and board in on-site barracks and
encouraged to explore the enclosure and
play with
scp-974 if 974 had not selected a victim
within five days the group of children
would be sent away and a new group would
be introduced this system worked for a
few years but as you might expect the
Ethics Committee had a problem with the
practice of offering up live children to
a deadly anomaly now as of January 1st
2015 the team at Zoological Reserve site
16 are no longer able to evoke protocol
12 in order to acquire children attempts
to use another SCP
scp-1680 a collection of clones of a
missing eight-year-old boy failed as
scp-974 refused to eat them the
procedures then changed to only allow
small animals to be introduced into the
enclosure as prey while it might seem
like this was a good idea that would
stop
scp-974 from killing any more children
like a lot of seemingly good changes to
containment procedures in the foundation
this well-intentioned move would
ultimately have deadly consequences
scp-974 at first seemed to behave
normally despite being denied its
favorite food but then on August 16 2015
while on their weekly sweep of the
enclosure Patrol teams found that 974
had destroyed all of the tree houses it
had built in its time and containment
the SCP itself was also nowhere to be
found there was something new in the
enclosure though a small oval of
disturbed soil a geological team was
called in and through ground penetrating
radar it was found that there was a
humanoid figure buried there curled up
in a fetal position this couldn't be
scp-974 could it the figure was much too
long and thin to be anything resembling
a human child but it had to be scp-974
it was the only living thing in the
enclosure the scientists were intrigued
and they theorized that the SCP might
have entered a new life stage further
scans were conducted over the next 10
days during that time the creature never
moved from its position though it did
continue to grow it seemed like it was
absorbing nutrients from the surrounding
soil the team decided to exhume the
creature to examine it when they dug it
up they found that scp-974 had stretched
out now measuring 220 centimeters in
length and weighing just 37.4 kilograms
it had no features or orifices of any
kind anywhere on its body and it's now
pale white skin was covered in some kind
of sticky mucus that when examined was
found to contain a previously
undiscovered enzyme the creature was
alive but barely it wasn't breathing and
its heartbeat was extremely slow almost
to the point of being undetectable
scp-974 was examined for an additional
four weeks after which it died and was
sent for dissection some of the
scientists and researchers at Zoological
site 16 were disappointed to hear about
974's death as vicious and feral as the
creature was they developed a certain
fondness for it and its many tree houses
luckily it wouldn't be too much longer
until a new specimen was obtained on
October 16 2016 a group of no less than
seven instances of scp-974 were
discovered near a major American city
the containment team was forced to kill
six of the anomalies in the attempts to
capture them but one instance survived
and was taken to Zoological site 16. as
was mandated the area was burned and
Foundation counterintelligence
disseminated a cover story about a
forest fire caused by an improperly
extinguished campfire the new scp-974
was like the original one placed in the
enclosure and denied human prey also
like the first one this 974 buried
itself after being denied its preferred
meals for several months the decision
was made to leave the SCP underground
longer than the first instance to see
what it might become if this
developmental stage wasn't interrupted
on January 25th 2017 the creature
finally dug itself free from the earth
now designated
scp-974-a it was far more aggressive
than any instance of 974 had ever been
before as soon as it was free from the
dirt it made a beeline straight for the
nearest monitoring station it ripped the
roof off and tore the 16 members
stationed there to show threads in just
90 seconds when the response team
arrived 15 minutes later only 12 percent
of the human remains were able to be
recovered but strangely enough it at
first seemed like one of the team had
been spared Georgia Stone one of the
monitoring team was severely injured but
apparently in a stable condition
disoriented she approached the response
team begging for assistance and urging
them to take her out of the enclosure
but the team was skeptical they knew
that scp-974 could become an exact copy
of any child that consumed so it
followed that the fully grown
scp-974-a might be able to copy adults
they asked Georgia questions in order to
confirm her identity but she was unable
to answer them having being found out
scp-974 still mimicking Georgia attacked
the response team they'd been armed with
flamethrowers but unfortunately on top
of its resistance to damage the adult
form of 974 didn't seem to be afraid of
of or harmed by fire the team was at a
loss for how to kill this thing or even
subdue it long enough to get out safely
scp-974-a was tearing through the
members of the team like they were made
out of paper thinking quickly one member
of the response team a guard named
Emilio pulled out one of his standard
issue Foundation hand grenades when
scp-974-a came at him he pulled the pin
and holding the grenade shoved his arm
into the creature's open mouth while the
explosion destroyed Emilio's arm it
didn't even break the skin of
scp-974-a however it did result in
serious damage to its internal organs
which finally killed it following its
death an autopsy was conducted revealing
enough about the creature that a new
file of effective methods of
extermination was able to be created
after this event the protocols for
scp-974 containment were completely
overhauled any instances of scp-9 74-a
seen in the wild are to be killed as
quickly as possible more disturbingly
though the Ethics Committee rescinded
their previous decision and any
instances of 974 that are brought into
containment are to be provided with
human prey again letting scp-974 kill
children might not be a very humane way
of keeping it contained but given how
much more aggressive and hard to kill
this scp's adult form is any option that
stops the creature's metamorphosis from
happening is likely the best option in
the long run so remember if you're ever
out in the woods and see a crudely
constructed Tree House perhaps think
twice about how innocent it is there
could be something hungry lurking inside
one fine morning your distant Aunt Carol
came to your family home in an almost
frantic state of excitement Carol had
always been a bit eccentric totally
harmless of course but what you describe
as being on the more zealous side of
religious predicted she wanted to ask
you and your family to come to church
with her seeing as you don't see her on
Carol often you and your family decide
that there's no harm in indulging her
you're not an atheist family by any
means in fact you're all race Catholic
but it felt like it'd been forever since
you last went to church Aunt Carol
wanted to show you and your family the
special celebrations that went on at her
church you remember her practically
grabbing you by the wrist and dragging
you to the building her eyes filled with
a crazed enthusiasm that's when you saw
something incredibly strange there were
Shadows moving behind the elaborate
stained glass windows thousands of tiny
Shadows starting around and this low
humming noise you faintly recognize what
was that noise it was the Cry of cicadas
but this was only early spring what were
cicadas doing awake at this time of year
you didn't get much time to ponder this
question in the next few seconds you and
the entire church were rounded by heavy
duty tactical Vehicles what appeared to
be a large and heavily armed SWAT team
poured out of the vehicles unbeknownst
to you these were a mobile task force
sent in by the SCP Foundation
specifically
mtfy99 also known as The Altar Boys a
specially trained group of foundation
agents used for anomalies of a religious
nature you your aunt and the rest of
your family are rounded up to be
debriefed and given amnestics one of the
last memories they took from you was the
side of foundation agents dragging
bloody bodies out of the church as the
doors open thousands of cicadas streamed
out and disappeared into the skies but
these weren't like any kind of cicada
you'd ever seen they were beautiful the
rainbow colored Wings reminded you of
ornate stained glass who could have
guessed that these pretty little bugs
are tied to an entity very likely to
bring about an XK Class end of the world
scenario someday in the future the bugs
the bodies in the church and even your
aunt's incredibly strange Behavior All
Fall underneath the umbrella of a ketter
class anomaly known as
scp-3004 but to truly understand this
anomaly that was once thought to be
destroyed and the implications of it
still living today we need to go back
600 years to Ireland in the 15th century
this era was believed to be the origin
of a Gaelic religious movement known as
katelaji or the singers in English a
splinter sect of druidism but this was
no fringe cult the singers were a
mainstream religion in the British Isles
for several hundred years its members
included people of all social classes
from lowly peasants to powerful and
respected figures they mingled heavily
with Christians mostly Irish Catholics
and at some point in history came close
to overtaking Christianity as the
dominant religion in Ireland so who were
these people if there's supposedly such
a large part of recent history in the
area like most Druids their relationship
with nature was a key part of their
belief system in particular they prized
an extinct species of cicada known as
sycadera luculenta or the stained glass
cicada in English the life cycle of
birth and resurrection that the cicadas
underwent fascinated the singers and
they performed a number of holy rituals
around it one recorded ritual was the
celebration of children entering
adulthood that was marked by them first
losing their baby teeth but the rituals
of the singers accidentally opened some
kind of door to a being from a different
plane of reality dubbed
scp-3004-1 by the foundation this being
is an immensely powerful font form that
the foundation believes to be a pitis
phage or faith eater it appears to have
been attracted to our universe by the
rituals of the singers and so took a
form relevant to their beliefs namely a
huge cicada in order to feed on their
faith if things had stopped there then
this would be an almost innocent
symbiotic relationship but the
interactions between
scp-3004-1 and our world led to
dangerous consequences due to its
powerful reality warping abilities for
example during some rituals huge numbers
of stained glass cicadas would burst
from the mouths of those participating
often causing them to choke to death
other times 3004-1 would manifest
physically in the sky above its new
worshipers causing painful boils on
whoever witnessed it and occasionally
symptoms akin to radiation sickness it
appeared that 3004-1 was growing more
powerful over time and its rise to power
was intrinsically linked to the rituals
of the singers and the existence of the
stained glass cicadas two groups that
predated the foundation the vatican's
congregation for otherworldly acts and
the English government's Royal Society
for the imprisonment of abnormality
essentially performed an all-out
religious genocide on the singers no
meaningful trace of the religion was
left when they were done aside from
their own records while they were at it
they also exterminated all the stained
glass cicadas leading to a complete stop
of all scp-3004 activity it seemed like
despite the great human and ecological
cost the anomaly had been neutralized a
few centuries later though a series of
strange cicada-related anomalous events
started to occur across the United
States a strange man seemingly made
almost entirely from cicada kinten would
appear at christenings weddings and
funerals each time his presence would
cause the people in attendance to do and
experience horrific things and lead to
legacies of hardship and death that
would linger for decades this became
known as
scp-2852 or cousin Johnny and it should
have been the first clue that the
nightmare of
scp-3004 was resurfacing but since 3004
was already archived as neutralized
nobody made the connection some time
later
scp-2852 incident seized and around that
exact time
scp-3004 instances started Anew it
manifested in the form of strange
anomalous activities taking place at
Christian church services specifically
those from Roman Catholic Eastern
Catholic Anglican and Episcopalian
communities the only Clues to Outsiders
would be an increase in reported Church
attendance and an increase in deaths
from natural causes within the community
these two stats were how the foundation
first noticed something was amiss just
as it had done with the singers
centuries before
scp-3004-1 had latched onto the beliefs
and rituals of Christians and was using
this new connection to harvest more
faith for sustenance the results were
twofold first religious fever and
excitement to attend church services saw
a huge increase secondly the actual
content of these Services took a hard
turn for the horrific much like cousin
Johnny infiltrations this really isn't
for the faint of heart by any definition
for example young people with
christ-like Stigmata wounds being bitten
to death by priests children removing
the teeth of priests before they all
start vomiting huge numbers of stained
glass cicadas that were extremely
unpleasant rituals involving castration
and even a pregnant woman giving birth
to even more swarms of stained glass
cicadas we could go on but you probably
get the idea rituals inspired by
scp-3004-1 are horrific and all seem to
involve the same extinct breed of
stained glass cicadas worshiped by the
singers before their Annihilation but
how can these insects which have been
dubbed
scp-3004-2 be here in the present if the
foundation forerunners made them extinct
so many centuries ago the answer is
simple but strange while they have all
the Hallmarks of being alive the stained
glass cicada is present during modern
iterations of scp-3004 events aren't
actually real genetic tests have shown
that they're actually made from a mix of
wood and real stained glass these
insects Fly Away From The Scene after
the rituals are completed traveling
around 600 miles from the site before
disappearing completely the foundation
was growing concerned about the nature
of scp-3004 especially given that
instances were becoming more frequent
and harder to contain Foundation
scientists determined that the creature
known as 3004-1 likely existed within a
layer of reality just above our own and
if it ever managed to breach our reality
the World level of violence and Chaos it
could cause would likely lead to an XK
Class end of the world scenario drastic
actions would once again be needed to
prevent this so they devised an
emergency containment procedure that
would only be used as a last resort the
procedure known as protocol damantio
audbestias would use a mixture of mass
amnesic treatment and thermal objects to
completely erase Christianity from not
only the modern world but all history in
hopes of cutting off
scp-3004-1's food supply to kill the
entity or at least prevent it from
entering our world the plan would Center
on placing a powerful Roman Catholic
reality warper who volunteered for the
job of course into an anomalous group of
machines known as the Lions by
submitting the reality warper to a
lifetime of suffering and essentially
erasing him from existence so too will
it erase the world's full knowledge of
Christianity and hopefully save the
world this man will become the last
martyr dying for all of humanity he will
become the last Saint Saint Jude the
Damned bulwark against Darkness you
might ask are you sure that's necessary
there's so much we don't know about
3004-1 do we know for a fact that it's
dangerous enter agent Timothy Letterman
a member of mobile task force Sigma 25
also known as Ghostbusters Letterman was
part of a foundation project known as
sightsee Lux using an astral projection
technology that would free his
Consciousness from his body and allow it
to travel freely between metaphysical
planes in plain English they could use
Letterman's floating mind as a kind of
spy and insert it into
3004-1's Dimension they achieved this by
capturing one of 3004-1's false stained
glass cicadas and releasing it again
allowing Letterman's mind to follow it
home to its Master however what we
thought would be a simple Intel
gathering mission turned into a complete
nightmare Letterman found that 3004-1's
Dimension was entirely void aside from
the entity itself and the millions of
buzzing stained glass cicadas The Entity
was so huge and so complex that it
physically hurt to look at Letterman
observed that its form kept shifting
from a giant cicada to an old man to a
cicada nailed to a wooden cross to an
infinite mess of wood and stained glass
but even more terrifying than its
physical appearance were the contents of
its mind 3 3004-1 forced itself into
agent Letterman's brain and in that
moment he finally understood it the
entity which had no concept of metaphors
allegory or the Divide between fact and
fiction truly believed that it was the
abrahamic god depicted in the Bible and
that all Christians are lovingly
worshiping it in its rituals it was
imposing some of the bloodiest parts of
the Bible onto its flock believing
that's what they wanted all the while it
fed on their faith growing bigger and
more powerful Letterman found that just
being there with the creature was
hurting his soul if it wasn't a god yet
he believed it had the power to become
one in time and he advised the
foundation shouldn't send anyone else to
its Dimension it was too great a risk to
all life on Earth perhaps to prevent the
horrible fate of all of us being
destroyed by 3004-1 erasing Christianity
would be a worthy sacrifice that is if
it actually works after all they thought
destroying the singers would neutralize
3004 once and for all and yet here it is
again for all we know we may just be
prolonging the inevitable we all have
fond memories of the playground hours
upon hours spent in Blissful childhood
abandon racing around the local park
climbing the monkey bars and seeing if
you could get even higher on the swings
than your best friend and then of course
there's the slide who doesn't love a
slide only you and the force of gravity
pulling you down through a straight or
spiral tube those few seconds of
excitement that Rush of not knowing
whether you'll come out the other end of
the slide or not that's enough of a
thrill for any kid of course you would
always come tumbling out of the mouth of
the slide every time at worst with an
odd but innocent friction burn on your
leg or arm but what if one day you
didn't come out of the other end or
Worse what if the place at the end of
this slide wasn't the world you left
behind when you slid through the
entrance it doesn't seem all that likely
to happen right well you've obviously
never taken a trip down
scp-1562 better known as the tunnel
slide as its moniker suggests
scp-1562 is a slide or it at least
appears to be an ordinary tunnel slide
you know the kind that you would easily
find at any kids park jungle gym or
indoor play area just over 2 meters high
and almost three and a half meters long
and for the most part it is a completely
normal slide if you were to just sit in
it and glide down its feet first nothing
would happen then again if
scp-1562 was an ordinary everyday piece
of a playground then the SCP Foundation
would not have such a vested interest in
it they definitely wouldn't be keeping
it locked up in quarantine secured in
Testing Lab 46-v of 524 and if any
foundation agents ask you didn't hear
that from us by the way the door to the
lab is kept locked at all times no
member of personnel is even allowed near
the slide unless granted special
clearance to do so by Foundation
researcher Dr Carver so what is it that
makes this thing so special well for one
scp-1562 was first recovered by the
foundation from a defunct abandoned
playground the location of this
playground has been redacted but it was
known to be on the outskirts of a town
where a number of young children had
been reported missing does scp-1562
contain some sort of clue as to where
these children were taken perhaps some
piece of forensic evidence left behind
by a child snatching anomaly From
Another Dimension not quite
scp-1562 is the thing that took those
children you see the slide's anomalous
properties require very specific
circumstances in order to activate like
we mentioned earlier if you were just
sitting on your butt while you were
sliding down it you would Escape
unscathed laying flat on your back that
is also a safe option even flailing
yourself about spinning and rolling and
waving your arms changing position on
the way down would mean that nothing
anomalous would appear to happen however
if someone enters
scp-1562 and travels down in head first
laying on their stomach with their arms
tucked at their side almost in a plank
position then that is when strange
things start to happen that is when a
person finds out what happened to those
missing children only about 15
centimeters from the opening of the
slide a person sliding down on their
front head first With Arms by their
sides will disappear right before
exiting
scp-1562 in an instant they will simply
be gone no longer in the slide or even
relocated to anywhere nearby to make
matters worse every single person that
this has happened to has never been
found and again they literally have
vanished off the face of the Earth
unfortunately there isn't much that can
be done to prevent this during testing
the foundation quickly learned that
tethering a safety line to a subject
does little to stop them from
disappearing they cannot be pulled back
from wherever it is that the slide sends
them the Rope they are attached to is
simply cut and goes slack from the
moment that a person is taken by the
slide now that sounds like the whole
story right children are going missing
and the foundation learns it's because
of
scp-1562 some kind of interdimensional
portal within a playground slide so they
acquired the slide take it away and keep
it locked up securely where it can't
cause any more disappearances end of
story except that's not quite the end no
the one thing it's still possible to do
once someone has disappeared on the
slide is to stay in contact with them
the SCP Foundation has expended a number
of test subjects by Sen sending them
sliding down
scp-1562 just to learn what's on the
other side just where does the slide
take them luckily tests like this are
precisely what the foundation has
d-class Personnel for so what happened
when the foundation sent some d-classes
on a one-way Joyride down the slide
while one test involved a d-class
designated
d-2445 who disappeared into
scp-1562 but was given a two-way radio
to communicate directly with Dr deritz
one of the research staff
d2445 reported that he felt himself in a
small cramped tunnel and quickly
requested to be let back out Dr daretz
had neglected to tell d2445 that was
impossible and that no one ever came
back from inside the slide while it was
too dark to see anything The Prisoner
described still being laid on his front
but feeling like there were rocks or
dirt surrounding him on all sides
realizing that he barely had enough room
to move or even lift his head d 2445
again requested to be let out of
scp-1562 as the unfortunate d-class grew
increasingly more unsettled by the
movement restricting environment Dr
derritz revealed that the lifeline
tethering d2445 back to the foundation
had been severed upon their
disappearance into the slide panicking
d-2445 managed to move forward slightly
and realized that his head had hit
something a shoe a tiny child's shoe
communication with d-2445 was called to
a halt and the foundation's researchers
discussed possible ways that they could
retrieve the prisoner although most of
them probably knew at this point that
this task was likely impossible this
test may have taken place before the
foundation realized the return from
scp-1562 was impossible the plan was
that another t-class would be sent into
the slide once again they would be
attached to a tether line and be
carrying video and audio recording
equipment along with the GPS tracker and
a headlamp reaching out to d2445 Dr
daritz relayed this plan to him
d-2445 immediately begged to be set free
from
scp-1562 as the doctor attempted to calm
him down but too little a fact something
had scared him truly terrified him a
sound coming from somewhere within the
tunnel it started talking
d-2445 claimed when Dr daritz asked for
clarity the d-class replied saying that
a little boy had tried to speak to him
but that the child had made little sense
he just kept asking where he was and I
told him I didn't know but I don't think
he was really talking to me because he
didn't respond to my voice and he told
me to stop crying when I was actually
sort of calm when asked if this child
had moved at all
d2445 said that he was unsure he started
screaming and I told him to shut up but
he just kept screaming and crying and
asking for his mommy and then he finally
stopped and sure shortly after that
you've contacted me again
please get me out now Dr derrett's tried
to reassure the man to little Avail and
communication with d-2445 was cut off
after he claimed something was wrong
with his chest shortly after the
foundation lost communication with
d-2445 another member of d-class was
sent into the slide after him this
subject referred to officially as D 8600
had been specifically selected for this
task thanks to his small stature Dr
daritz and the other Foundation
researchers testing
scp-1562 believed that the man's thinner
body type would allow d-8600 to better
navigate the tunnel that the slides
seemed to transport people to and you
can probably guessed what happened next
just like all the others that had been
sent down the slide
d-8600 was trapped his Lifeline was cut
the moment that he vanished inside the
tunnel slide on top of this the GPS
tracker that this thinner d-class had
been issued with seemed to not be
working properly its signal could not be
correct traced and without an accurate
fix there was no way to determine the
location to which
scp-1562 was transporting its victims if
it was even in this universe
Additionally the video feed from the
camera d8600 was carrying also failed to
connect with only audio from his radio
being recovered by the research team
contacting d8600 Dr derritz was informed
by this new d-class that his headlamped
had stopped working the second he had
arrived in the same cave or tunnel as
earlier test subjects before long by
shimmying through the area on his arms
d8600 bumped into a foot believed to be
belonging to
d-2445 while he could barely see
anything d-8600 could hear
d2445's voice and this was being faintly
picked up via His Radio however as he
and Dr daritz tried to talk to the first
prisoner his words began to sound all
too familiar I don't know some sort of
very small tunnel it's really cramped
can you get me out now followed by no
it's it's too dark I can't see anything
and I'm stuck it was all just a
recording from what d2445 had said when
he first arrived after
scp-1562 had sent him into the tunnel
d8600 did not realize this at first and
attempted to help his fellow prisoner
hoping to pull him out of wherever they
were trapped Dr Derricks tried
desperately to explain the d2445 was
just repeating his half of an earlier
conversation but D 8600 hardly noticed
that was the case he gripped the other
d-class's ankles and told the doctor to
pull them out of the tunnel the doctor
revealed that once again the tether line
had been severed but d8600 refused to
believe that escape was impossible he
tried to worm his way back the way he
had come leaving d-2445 still repeating
his words from earlier he just kept
asking me where he was and I told him I
didn't know but I don't think he was
really talking to me because he didn't
respond to my voice and he told me to
stop crying when I was actually sort of
calm I don't think so he started
screaming and I told him to shut up but
he kept just screaming and crying and
asking for his mommy then he finally
stopped and shortly after that you
contacted me again
please get me out now please hurry my
chest is really starting to hurt after
yelling at him to stop talking multiple
times D 8600 noted that d2445 had
finally gone quiet the d-class also
remarked that the air was starting to
taste stale and hope that there would be
enough oxygen for him to get back then
just like his predecessor communication
with d8600 came to an abrupt stop Dr
derritz was no longer able to reach him
on the radio there was nothing but
static the foundation was unable to
re-establish contact with either of the
two d-class Personnel lost inside
scp-1562 and any future testing of the
tunnel slide was suspended to this day
none of us know what exactly happened to
the victims of the tunnel slide where
were they taken what had taken them what
was making the prior victims repeat
their ominous words as horror author
Stephen King once put it it's the
unanswered questions that stays with us
the longest but the next time you decide
to Thrill your inner child by taking a
jean to your local Kitty Park you may
just find out for yourself if you ever
take a trip across the pond to some of
the more rural parts of the British
Isles you might just hear some Tales of
a dark shadowy shame a creature stalking
through the night an omen of death it's
an entity that has been known by many
names including the Grim or black shock
most folks will tell you the same that
this nightmare takes on the form of a
huge black dog but is also known to be
able to change its shape often appearing
at night time The Apparition is said to
be demonic in nature commonly associated
with the Devil Himself believed by some
to be a hellhound like garmer and
Cerberus Guardians of the underworld in
Norse and Greek mythology the dog is far
larger than your average pet with big
glowing eyes it is also known to stock
Crossroads ancient Pathways and places
where X executions took place those who
catch sight of black shuck are often
befallen with bad luck and for some it
can even mean that death will soon be
upon them of course this is nothing more
than a bit of local folklore details
designed to drum up tourism but is the
black shock really just a legend or is
there something more to the tale after
all it's not as if a dog like that could
really exist could it enter
scp-023 otherwise known as yes you
guessed it the black shock much like the
creatures from the stories
scp-023 is an entity possessing a canine
form far larger than most domesticated
dogs
scp-023 is described as being Shaggy in
appearance with black fur and glowing
orange red eyes as well as prominent
fangs through testing the SCP Foundation
has determined a number of the dog's
anomalous abilities first and foremost
Legends have described the black shock
as an apparition or spirit and much in
the same vein
scp-023 is able to pass right through
solid matter the creature can pass
through walls seemingly at will but does
also seem to have a physical form at
least when it is kept in containment to
prevent a breach the foundation keeps
scp-023 in a walled off intersection of
two corridors sporting fake doors at
three of its four ends with only one
real entrance why does the dog's
containment unit require such a specific
layout simple it has to resemble a
crossroad even if this is merely a
superficial resemblance remember that
the black shuck of Legend often appeared
at Crossroads a sign that would warn
those traveling of their impending doom
as long as scp-023 remains contained in
the cell resembling Crossroads it cannot
pass through walls should the black
shuck ever escape this enclosure however
then it will use its anomalous abilities
to incinerate anything in its path the
dog can burn through walls no matter how
dense and will travel from location to
location by this method also in keeping
with the shock of folklore looking into
the eyes of scp-023 can hold potentially
devastating outcomes should any person
make direct eye contact with the dog
then death will be upon them within the
span of the next full year either the
person who looked at the black shuck in
the eye or a close member of their
family will die just like a number of
the Legends State the foundation has no
concrete idea how the shuck chooses its
victims with no patterns or obvious
preferences only that they will die a
year after eye contact researchers
aren't even sure if scp-023 selects its
victims from the moment eye contact is
made or if this choice is made during
the year that follows or even if it is a
conscious choice at all all that is
known for certain is that if you were to
look into the beast's glowing eyes there
would be no way for you to tell if you
or a relative would suffer the
consequences only when in the past the
SCP Foundation attempted to eliminate an
individual that looked into
scp-023's eyes along with their their
whole family before the year was up
trying to take any potential victims
away from the black shuck before they
could be hunted down by the anomalous
canine much like the way the creature
passes through Walls by incinerating
solid matter the way scp-023 dispatches
its chosen victims seem to almost be
linked to the use of heat the foundation
has conducted a number of autopsies on
those killed by scp-023 and their
findings have always yielded the same
result anyone killed by the black shock
will not exhibit any signs of external
damage no burn marks on their skin or
any kind of contusions however on closer
inspection these bodies appear to have
been filled in their insides were placed
with highly compacted Ash all their
organs and internal bodily systems
appear to be incinerated by the black
shuck but somehow this occurs so rapidly
that there is no notable damage caused
to the outside of their bodies to
prevent scp-023 claim any further
victims the foundation has another
measure in place the black shuck has
been fitted with two spheres made of
hard rubber these are inserted into the
creatures sunken in eye sockets blocking
anyone from accidentally making eye
contact with it however over time thanks
to the heating effect of the shook State
these inserts will begin to degrade when
security cameras detect that the glow of
scp-023's eyes have returned to a
dangerous level Foundation Personnel
will have to replace the rubber spheres
to once again block the creature's
Vision however this can only be done
after Sunset and any Personnel tasked
with replacing the inserts are cautioned
not to look the dog in the eyes during
the process unless they want to become
the black Shucks next victim the SCP
Foundation first came into contact with
scp-023 when they received information
about an attack that had taken place at
a church while the location of this
incident is unknown if the Legends are
to be believed believe the church may
have been located in the Moors of a
rural region of the British Isles while
the church was in the middle of a
service the black shuck entered and
killed a number of civilians in
attendance presumably the members of
this congregation had all at some point
seen the large black dog out in the
Moors or one of their relatives had the
foundation stepped in and managed to
capture the black shuck giving amnestics
to the survivors that had witnessed the
attack the Damage Done by scp-023 and
the deaths it caused were covered up as
attempted arson however the foundation's
trouble with scp-023 was far from over
after the black Shucks capture at the
church the dog was able to breach
containment on multiple occasions at
first it had been placed in a standard
containment chamber but it was quickly
able to incinerate through the concrete
walls of the cell Foundation Personnel
later discovered that the dog had
settled in in an intersection between
two corridors and realized that it had
resembled a crossroad these exact
corridors became the basis for scp-023's
new containment chamber and the
assistant researcher originally assigned
to the dog was reprimanded for
negligence during this and other Escape
attempts scp-023 caused the deaths of a
high number of foundation personnel as a
direct result researchers assigned to it
requested that the black shock be
reclassified as a ketter class anomaly
they also noted that scp-023 shared
certain traits with
scp-111-1 of the two entities that form
scp-111
scp-111-1 also referred to as the white
dog possesses an almost ghostly
translucent canine form and abilities
that focus on Geographic space in the
white dog's case it will attack anyone
it detects approaching
scp-111-2 the body of an unidentified
man hanging from a news researchers
working for the foundation believe that
scp-023 and scp-11 11-1 might be
instances of the same phenomenon but
have been unable to capture the white
dog in order to verify this given the
number of deaths the black shuck had
caused research Personnel attempted to
reduce the danger that they faced when
interacting with the dog they helped to
remove the beast's eyes and teeth thus
making it safer however it was during an
attempt to do so that scp-023 once again
managed to breach containment at first
everything seemed to be going according
to plan but when researchers removed
scp-023's eyes the black Chuck vanished
completely from its containment area SCP
security staff scoured the area for it
eventually tracking the dog down to a
long stretch of Interstate it is still
unknown exactly how many civilians may
have seen the black shuck as they drove
past it but so far nine deaths are
thought to have stemmed from this
incident the ghostly dog was recaptured
and d-class Personnel removed its fangs
after analyzing the times of of
incidents researchers realized that
scp-023 had only been able to escape
while the sun was up leading to new
containment procedures mandating that no
staff member was to interact with the
shock until after Sunset the interstate
Fiasco led to the doctor assigned to
watch over
scp-023 being suspended and facing a
disciplinary review from his foundation
superiors the blame for the breach and
security that caused the incident was
placed at his feet and a new doctor was
placed in charge of observing the black
shock unfortunately for this new
researcher the incidents involving
scp-023 did not stop there the newly
appointed doctor attempted to give the
dog a pair of glass eyes to replace the
ones that had been removed before the
previous Containment Breach perhaps they
thought it was a gesture of kindness a
compassionate act or maybe they just
thought it would look cool for a dog to
have glass eyes no matter the reason it
seemed they had forgotten for a moment
that this huge shadow creature was an
ancient evil entity and not a dog at all
when the doctor gave the new glass eyes
to scp-023 they immediately took on the
exact same properties as its old ones
they began glowing molten glass leaking
from the dog's sockets and appeared on
all reflective surfaces throughout the
site the shuck was being held at
everything from mirrors and windows to
lenses and glasses computer monitors
anything and everything glass the
foundation suffered an enormous number
of deaths that day even staff sitting in
the cafeteria would have seen a version
of those orange glowing eyes staring at
them from the bottom of their bowls
marking them for a fiery death the
facility was quickly evacuated but the
damage had already been done anyone that
had seen a reflection of the black
shark's eyes would be dead within a year
devastated the new doctor in charge of
overseeing scp-023 blame themselves for
dooming their research team as as well
as the rest of the foundation staff in
the facility when the sun came up over
the horizon a number of d-class
personnel were sent into
scp-023's enclosure only to find that
the dog had once again vanished the only
trace it had left behind was a puddle of
molten glass burning part of the floor a
year later any and all Personnel that
had gazed into the black Shuck's eyes
were dead and the remains were buried in
a mass unmarked grave near the
containment facility despite the doctor
vowing to recapture and contain
scp-023 it remains unclear if there were
ever actually successful there is a
chance that the black shuck has been
gradually making its way back home to
the Moors of the British Isles if so we
advise you not to travel after Sundown
unless you absolutely have to and if you
find yourself at a crossroad then pray
you don't catch sight of a hulking
demonic Hound staring out at you with
eyes that burn through the dark if you
you do well we hope you enjoy your year
okay guys so to wrap this video up I
really don't think this cursed episode
of this show was real it's obviously
just a really good scary fan animation
and the fact that the creators behind it
didn't come out and claim ownership of
it sooner allowing it to be reposted and
re-uploaded so many times is really what
got people thinking was legit that being
said it's still a good attempt at what a
cursed Lost episode would look like so
shout out to those animators man anyway
I've been the goat hellholder 98 be sure
to like this video subscribe to my
channel down below and hey if you know
about any more lost media you want me to
cover leave it in the comments I'll
check it out and be sure to follow my
socials at hellholder98 I go live most
days and post updates about new videos
on my story so go check it out alright
until then I'll see you somewhere down
the line the moment his finger pushed
the button to stop the camera recording
the practiced false smile dropped from
Holden's face it was hard not to feel
down after he'd finished filming a new
video not thanks to any post creativity
slump but the a more depressing
knowledge of just how much of an uphill
battle this whole thing was it felt like
yesterday when Holden had first gotten
into the creepier side of the internet
he never ventured into anything illicit
or outright illegal mind you but there
was a distinct corner of the web that
had pulled him in when he was still at
school and just starting to spend more
time online this part of the internet
was filled with scary stories that were
mostly fake or made up for likes but
that could have been real there were
unsettling animations short clips that
were hand drawn to give people the
creeps and keep them up at night not to
mention a whole Archive of Public Safety
announcement videos terrifying workplace
and road safety warnings that used to be
broadcast on TV and were as petrifying
than the most acclaimed horror movies
speaking of things that were broadcast
to TV that had gradually become Holden's
specialty one of his friends had sent
him the link to a fictional account of
someone who had supposedly uncovered an
unaired episode of a Saturday morning
kids cartoon or so this person claimed
anyway they went on to describe bizarre
imagery so intense and terrifying that
it was unbefitting of a show for
children then the person who made the
original post explained how they got
into contact with the show's creators
via email to ask them about this cursed
episode The showrunner responded stating
that the episode the poster had
allegedly seen didn't even exist to
Holden it didn't matter if the story was
real or not that wasn't the point what
was far more important was that it felt
real to him it was plausible even
possible that there were pieces of media
out there in the world that had never
seen the light of day episodes of TV
shows or entire movies that were so wild
and out there that they could have been
banned and buried long before the dawn
of the internet wherein there was a
record of everything and nothing was
ever really lost the idea of uncovering
those lost pieces of media became
Holden's primary hobby he come home from
school throw his backpack onto his bed
and then sit in front of his computer
for hours without even changing out of
the clothes he had been wearing all day
in class but all the time he spent
trawling through form threads following
and messaging collectors on social media
listening to theories and coming up with
his own eventually it began to encroach
on other things much to his mom's
disappointment Holden's grades took a
rapid decline it wasn't long before he
was failing his classes bad enough to
not make the cut to continue on at
school but as much as it upset his
mother Holden really didn't mind he was
already thinking Way Beyond high school
and he knew he didn't need grades to be
able to do the one thing he wanted to do
with his life Holden set up his own
Channel with the plan to start uploading
videos under his new online alter ego
and before long hell holder 98 was born
he centered his whole internet Persona
around lost media discussing which
popular rumors were true and which were
fictionalized for likes and clicks it
started out with a few discussion videos
where he would simply sit in his bedroom
a camcorder opposite him as he spoke but
before long Holden was adding more and
more Flair to his content learning how
to edit on his computer adding Clips or
screenshots he could find of supposed
Lost TV episodes to give his videos some
credibility a very necessary quality
when trying to determine if certain
things were real or not each video he
finished he had another two topics to a
list of ideas he kept planning to just
perpetually churn out content until he
eventually had a huge hit that went
viral although the one thing he didn't
realize until it was perhaps too late
was that social media success didn't
happen overnight in fact it didn't
happen over many many nights either no
matter how often Holden promoted his
channel on his social media profiles or
how many new videos he uploaded he
couldn't seem to get any to land well
and get boosted by the algorithm at
least that's one of the things he
attributed the problem to he point the
finger of blame at anything that he
could one day it was that the algorithm
was suppressing his channel and boosting
others who had already got more
subscribers the next it might be his
slow internet connection had led to one
of his videos going live at a time when
the site had low traffic the one
possibility that Holden didn't stop to
consider was that maybe his genre of
content was too Niche without the days
of the internet's interest in Lost media
had already peaked back when he was
still in high school nevertheless he
kept trying making content day in and
day out working under the assumption
that if he just made enough videos then
one day he was sure to blow up that
would be his big break his ultimate win
a video that did well enough to Garner
thousands if not millions of views but
the more time he devoted to Hal holder
98 the only number that seemed to be at
all increasing was the number of videos
he had posted each one barely garnering
view figures that were above a single
digit to make matters worse getting help
with growing his online brand was next
to Impossible every now and then he
would post on forms asking for advice or
if anyone wanted to collaborate so he
could gain some exposure from creators
with bigger followings those posts were
often met with a slew of apathetic snide
responses or comments telling Holden 2
just quote make better content as if
that was solid specific advice on top of
that his mom had outright refused to
support her son's chosen career path
citing his failure at school as the main
reason speaking of any friends Holden
previously had at school had all moved
away in the years since going off to
pursue college and other higher
education some were even starting their
new and exciting professions the old
saying said it's Lonely at the Top but
Holden was just as lonely down at the
bottom posting his content in total
obscurity as if he was just shouting
into an empty void with no one around to
hear the few people Holden did still
consider his friends were all as
chronically online as he was most of
them fellow lost media collect doctors
after interacting with them in the
common threads of various forums the
handful of like-minded guys were as
close as Holden had to people actively
supporting his channel the collectors
would usually give him pointers or
topics to discuss in videos and
contributing to the single digit view
count underneath his uploads although to
him it wasn't nearly enough he didn't
want just his friends to see his videos
he wanted an audience a fan base of his
own it was late the light of the
computer monitor Illuminating the dark
of Holden's bedroom hunched over his
desk he was clicking and dragging clips
into the timeline of a video project
trimming them down to make the whole
thing better paced snipping out bad
takes where he stumbled over his words
or misspoke it was while editing that
Holden noticed another screen lighting
up on his desk accompanied by a
vibration his phone he reached for it
seeing a notification popped up on the
lock screen it was from goth one of the
Lost media collectors and it read dude
urgent found something that you can make
a video on hold inside it was late it
was already focused on editing this
current video tonight if you got it
finished then he could go to sleep what
do you know about the deathly videotape
goeth asked in a second message before
Holden even had a chance to open it
first the what he replied bluntly before
sending another text saying can't this
wait until the morning I'm trying to
edit if you don't act fast it'll be gone
forever came the response only a second
later followed by a link lethargically
hold and tapped the hyperlink oath had
sent his phone opening up its browser
and displaying the web page it was a buy
and sell website one of those places
where people offloaded junk they didn't
want anymore to strangers for a bit of
extra cash the page in question showed a
few grainy photos taken on a phone of a
small rectangular object in someone's
hand what is that Holden asked it's a
videotape bonehead goth fired back
although they'd never met in person
Holden always got the sense his friend
was a little older than he was looking
back on the seller's ad it was for a
secondhand Sony color collection 60 to
90 minute mini DV videotape a type of
cassette used in a lot of old handheld
recording cameras so what holdenast in
another text look there have been rumors
for ages about something called The
Deathly videotape both replied in a
series of Rapid Fire messages it used to
be all the rage on a lot of old lost
media forums the real nasty ones before
they got shut down supposedly there's a
recording on this tape of some kind of
live show except when you put in your
VCR and press play you see something
horrible nobody even knows if it's real
or just a legend how do you know this is
the same tape Holden queried by now he
had typed out the same link on his
computer and was looking at the for sale
page on the bigger screen while he
texted back and forth with goth read the
item description he answered Holden's
eyes scanned down the page finding a
short message from the seller to anyone
interested I'm giving this old Mini DV
tape away I don't know where I got it or
why I watched it but I wish I hadn't it
had ruined everything for me it's
impossible to enjoy anything else now
that I've seen what's on it let me make
this clear I am not selling this tape
I'm giving it away free of charge I hope
that getting rid of it will help sounds
ominous holding texted if you're so sure
if this is the deathly videotape then
why don't you get it keep reading growth
responded underneath the item
description was another note that the
seller had written please note I am
unable to leave my town at present nor
can I mail this tape to anyone even if
you pay postage collection only if
you're interested please contact me at
the following address below was an
address it was in Holden's Hometown only
a few streets away from where he and his
mom lived this could be it dude came
another slew of messages from gov you
buy this tape and make a video recording
then you might finally go viral but you
better be quick before someone goes and
picks it up thinking it's just an
ordinary tape Holden looks back at the
address double tracking where it was at
most it'd take a quick walk there and
back he thought and if this tape was as
elusive as ghost said it was then owning
it would mean Holden would be the only
one who could make a video featuring it
after messaging the seller the night
before Holden found himself rushing
through his quiet neighborhood to the
address all night as he tried to sleep
he kept thinking of the video he was
going to make how he could finally put
him on the map and at long last bring
him the e-fame he'd been working towards
wrapping his knuckles against the front
door he was met by an older man who
stood on the other side he was walking
with a crutch with a few bruises and
stitched up cuts on his face the second
that Holden explained he was there for
the tape the man reached to an unseen
shelf just inside the door frame and
thrust the rectangular cassette into his
hands before shutting the door as
quickly as he could without it hitting
Holden Square in the face he stared at
the tape in his hands though through its
transparent green plastic case he could
see a hand scrawled note I know you'll
ignore me if I tell you not to watch
this it read so if you do then on your
own head be it having spent the rest of
the day looking up exactly what he'd
need to play such an old out modded
recording format
invert the footage to digital so he
could include it in his video Holden had
retrieved his mom's old VHS player from
the attic wiping the thick layer of dust
off of it it took a while for him to get
everything ready to go not just finding
the right adapters and cables to hook
the VCR up to his TV as well as linking
that to his computer plus angling his
camera right and making sure the ring
light he'd bought for filming was
putting enough focus on his face after
the substantial prep Holden took a deep
breath summoning up the faux excitement
and Stage smile before he hit the record
button on his camera what's up guys it's
hell holder98 here now today I've got a
real treat for you all so my friend go
shout out to him told me that a while
ago there was talk about something
called The Deathly videotape we found a
mini DV tape that we think might be that
very same tape so we're gonna watch it
and see if it's legit dropping his
Persona as his face turned away from the
camera Holden punched the play button on
the VHS player his eyes glued to the TV
screen as the camera's lens was fixated
on him okay nothing so far he observed
met with nothing but a blank black
scream suddenly after 12 seconds of
nothing the playback started instantly
and Holden started relaying what he was
seeing on the tape to the camera there
was no sound either because the
recording on the videotape was filmed
that way or Holden hadn't properly
figured out how to hook it up to the VHS
the video itself showed a recording of
Sesame Street Live and for the most part
just seemed pretty underwhelming
characters were up on stage their
puppeteers managing to stay out of sight
as they entertained their young audience
after two and a half minutes Holden was
starting to feel like he'd gone to all
this effort over what seemed to just be
someone's old unwanted home video just
as he was considering turning off the
camera and throwing the videotape in the
trash at almost the three minute Mark
something weird started happening on the
stage the actor playing one of the
bigger characters seemed to be having
some trouble instantly trying to pull
off his cumbersome costume much to the
distress of the kids in the audience
looking on and horror but it wasn't just
the illusion that had been broken the
actor was trying to get out of his
costume because he was choking he
dropped to his knees on stage clawing at
his own throat before Finally Falling
face down totally still asphyxiated dead
over the next almost 20 seconds the same
thing started happening to another three
of the characters on stage all of them
violently choking while the children in
the audience screamed and cried silently
on the inaudible tape then at three and
a half minutes the video cut out Holden
was unsure how to react at first a
little creeped out only to be somewhat
bemused he played it down for the camera
remarking that the video seemed tame
compared to some of the more graphic
fake content he'd seen but the whole
time even after rapping recording
sitting awake all night to edit his
reaction video blurring out the parts
that would break the terms of service he
had no idea what he'd seen was actually
real or not finishing the final edit
just as the sun was coming up hold and
hit upload and crawled into bed while
his video was uploaded the buzz of a
text message from goth awoke him dude I
told you this video was going to make it
big without even replying Holden booted
up his computer and opened the page for
his newly uploaded video The View count
was already in the thousands and
climbing comments pouring in underneath
mostly from people debating whether or
not the contents of the tape had been
faked Holden punched the air and
excitement he'd finally done it but as
the video kept playing he heard a
wretching sound coming from the computer
speakers he turned to look back at his
earlier self filmed only the night
before except what he was seeing play
out on screen now wasn't what he
remembered happening last night it
couldn't have because the Holden in that
video was choking that wasn't possible
he was alive and watching his own video
right now but somehow the footage was
shown him dying his Airway blocked face
turning red then blue was tears streamed
on his cheeks in the video hell holder
98 fell down dead from asphyxiation and
watching it made Holden feel sick to
make matters worse none of the comments
under the video seem to have witnessed
the same ending Holden even texts goeth
to ask if the same thing had happened
but he described the ending exactly as
Holden remembered filming it but
afterwards it didn't stop happening
everything he watched ended the same
every clip online every TV show every
movie Holden couldn't even read a book
without some characters fictional or
otherwise Keeling over and choking to
death just like the characters on the
tape he barely had time to acknowledge
the hits his reaction to the deathly
videotape we're getting he was too busy
trying to figure out why he couldn't
stop seeing people dying the exact same
way even himself when he watched back
his old hellholder 98 videos reacting to
the deathly videotape garnered a
respectable 3 million views but
hellholder 98 never uploaded again
afterwards his channel went silent
remembered only as a one hit wonder
until the video and the entire Channel
were down Holden was never reported
missing the foundation made sure of that
when they came by to collect scp-583 and
placed the videotape into containment
who doesn't love a walk through a dark
Forest the site of branches set against
the low Moonlight looking like all
manner of dark and twisted claws
reaching out of the night to grab at you
every step brings with it the snap of a
Broken Twig that practically Echoes
around you whenever a breeze rustles the
leaves on the trees you feel like
something might just be following you
moving through the forest towards you it
is easy to get lost in a force at night
after all that's why the children's song
warns us that if you go down to the
woods today you'd better not go alone
the image of a forest in the darkness
has inspired fear for Generations from
Fireside folk tales telling of wolves
and monsters lurking among the trees to
Modern horror games about a tall
faceless man in a suit stalking you
through the woods and then of course
there's scp-060 otherwise known as The
Infernal occult skeleton now despite the
name as cp060 is in actual fact a forest
or at least it's a forest to begin with
a picturesque Grove of 17 tall white oak
trees spread out across eight acres of
land in rural Northeast Minnesota it
almost looks like something out of a
tourist brochure a beautiful stretch of
forests sitting under clear skies well
during the daytime anyway if you ever
find yourself hiking through a corner of
Minnesotan Forest that isn't in any of
the guidebooks then tread carefully you
might just stumble upon the demolished
ruins of a house that used to stand
among the trees out in seclusion and a
word of advice to you if you happen
across this place do not under any
circumstances stop walking for a smoke
break of course thanks to the good Folks
at the SCP Foundation you're unlikely to
ever just wander your way into
scp-060 more likely they'll administer
you with amnestics the foundation's
patented memory altering drugs and send
you on your Merry way totally oblivious
to the huge hard to miss greenhouses
containing
scp-060 Beyond those Glass Walls you
might have caught glimpses of foundation
Personnel watering the trees carefully
tending to each
scp-060 specimen maybe you saw them
Gathering up leaves and pruning each
tree individually composting every part
of dead plant matter instead of leaving
the White Oaks to grow freely and
perhaps you even notice that not one
member of personnel was carrying a
lighter on their person nor a taser or
so much as a small box of matches
nothing that can start a fire or rather
you would remember seeing all that if
the amnestics hadn't already made you
forget but what's so special about these
freeze why would the SCP Foundation go
to the extent of housing a collection of
White Oaks in greenhouses and
meticulously oversee their growth what
is it about these particular specimens
that make Personnel so cautious about
fire safety and why on Earth is scp-060
a collection of trees referred to by the
nickname The Infernal occult skeleton
well the answer to all those questions
becomes pretty apparent the moment any
of the scp-060 oak trees Catch Fire and
something comes hurtling out of the
forest that something is known as
scp-060 Alpha standing at just over 2
meters tall The Entity takes the form of
an adult human skeleton much more than
just a spooky scary collection of Bones
scp-060 Alpha is fully animate capable
of moving of its own accord without the
aid of muscles or a nervous system oh
and it also happens to be on fire move
aside Ghost Rider scp-060 Alpha is in
goal from Skull to toe bones in bright
white Flames burning at a temperature of
approximately 1500 degrees Celsius or
almost 3 000 degrees Fahrenheit for
reference that's just shy of the melting
point of iron and hot enough to Grant a
human being a quick but agonizingly
painful death granted after a few
seconds of that heat your nerve endings
would be scalded so maybe you wouldn't
feel that much pain but 1500 Celsius is
enough to burn the moisture right out of
your skin melt your eyeballs and
generally fry you to a crisp in a matter
of minutes if not seconds good thing as
cp060 Alpha isn't known for being highly
aggressive and hostile oh wait it is ah
not good upon manifestation the burning
skeleton will attempt to do as much
damage as possible and usually to
whoever is closest it can appear at any
time and after as little as 20 grams
worth of one of the scp-060 trees is
burned as if being actively hostile and
burning hot enough to reshape metal
wasn't bad enough
scp-060 Alpha has also shown itself to
be fiercely intelligent The Entity seems
to retain knowledge whenever it
manifests and has gained a growing
familiarity with the layout of the
foundation site that contains the
scp-060 Oaks The Infernal occult
skeletons methods of attack tend to
include throwing its entire body at
flammable materials however it will
avoid causing any damage to specimens of
scp-060 the skeletal entity can run at
speeds up to 50 miles per hour now
that's almost the same speed as a
gazelle just picturing anything
traveling towards you at that speed is
horrifying let alone something headed
straight for you at gazelle levels of
speed while also on fire it is this
combination of speed and heat that means
scp-060 Alpha poses such a threat to
anyone close whenever it appears if left
unchecked the entity could easily cause
colossal and widespread forest fires and
property damage interestingly any areas
that scp-060 Alpha does burn with its
Flames will start to yield saplings of
the scp-060 Oaks around six weeks after
the fire has stopped the foundation
doesn't allow these saplings to grow to
full size and instead pulls them from
the ground and disposes of them
composting the saplings to feed the
other scp-060 specimens luckily the
biggest strength of scp-060 alpha its
Flames also happens to be its greatest
weakness it is possible to fight the
fires of the infernal occult skeleton by
dowsing it with water or any other
materials capable of dowsing flames
whether it's sand or foam from a fire
extinguisher of course this is a lot
hotter and harder to put out than any
ordinary smaller scale fire but despite
being a difficult task it is not
impossible about 500 liters of water
should do the trick if you've got a big
enough bucket nearby after that scp-060
Alpha will be weakened gradually
collapsing and turning into dust however
if another part of an scp-0603 is burned
and the entity reappears It is believed
that this will be the same infernal
occult skeleton rather than a new
version of the bone burning being so we
have a Grove of oak trees that manifest
a flaming skeleton if they are ever
burned maybe that's not the weirdest
thing you'd see in a Minnesotan Forest
but wait there's something else cast
your mind back a few minutes and you'll
remember that we mentioned some ruins
the remains of a demolished house that
used to stand secluded among the scp-060
white oak trees knowing that the
infernal occult skeleton can appear from
The Oaks might make it obvious what
happened to this house but there's still
a story to be told here The house's
owner was a man by the name of Jonathan
corehill now Jonathan was something of
an odd man considered a bit of an
eccentric Tucson he preferred to spend
his time in solitude alone with his own
thoughts for company rather than mango
among the rest of the world even his own
family noticed that Mr corehill was
drifting away from them becoming a more
bitter nihilistic person in his old age
and choosing isolation over human
connection now sure loneliness doesn't
hold much appeal to everyone but
sometimes there are people who just
prefer being alone that might be what
Drew Jonathan corehill to a secluded
Little House in the forests of Minnesota
somewhere no one would bother him for
the most part the rest of the corehill
family adjusted to their eccentric
relatives Behavior Jonathan would have
rarely accepted visitors to his house in
the forest but he still kept in contact
with those who he'd been close with most
notably he'd regularly share phone calls
with his brother one Christopher
corehill that is until something seemed
to change unexpectedly in the year 1996
on one of their calls Jonathan outright
told Christopher to never contact him
again severing any ties with any
remaining family members and friends in
the outside world old Jonathan cut
everyone off living within his own
bubble where he could immerse himself in
his unusual interests according to
Christopher his brother had seemed
otherwise normal up until a certain
phone conversation but Jonathan had
become obsessed with the occult
specifically he had embroiled himself in
the history of the Victorian era and
certain Supernatural practices that had
been undertaken in that time period now
whether Christopher honored his
brother's wish to sever ties is unknown
a mail carrier would visit Jonathan's
home in the woods not long after their
phone call maybe among the envelopes
this Courier was delivering what could
have been a letter from Christopher or
other members of the corehill family
begging they're a strange relative to
come back to the world you see even
people who claim to prefer being on
their own sometimes need human
interaction talking to people and being
in the presence of friends and family
are hugely important factors in
maintaining a positive state of mental
health but what happens when someone
rejects that entirely and instead
becomes lost in their obsessive study of
the occult while the mail carrier was
the first to find out arriving at
Jonathan corehill's Woodland house The
Courier found the place looking almost
skeletal a shell of the building that
had once stood in the forest according
to the locals the carrier had been sent
to deliver a notice to Mr corehill
explaining that his house was being
foreclosed but it seems someone or
something had beaten them to it a fire
had spread from The house's fireplace
quickly engulfing the entire structure
presumably with Jonathan still inside it
wasn't until later that very same year
that Jonathan corehill was officially
reported as a missing person case with
the local authorities any search that
was undertaken in an attempt to find him
uncovered next to no evidence of his
whereabouts to this day nobody knows for
certain if Jonathan corehill is dead or
alive his whereabouts are unknown on the
surface it might be easy to make the
assumption that the infernal occult
skeleton reduced the reclusive old man
to nothing more than a cinder it
definitely seems plausible that Jonathan
collecting firewood to keep himself warm
in his isolation accidentally chopped
down part of an scp-060 oak put it in
his fireplace and called forth the
vengeful flaming bones but perhaps we
shouldn't be so certain after all core
Hill's house wasn't entirely burned down
despite the entity normally trying to
cause as much damage as possible
whenever it appears and on top of that
no human remains were found in the house
and the skeleton of scp-060 alpha had to
have come from somewhere right
scp-060 offers a few warnings and not
just about the dangers of traveling
through the forest alone the appearance
of the Flaming skeleton whenever the
scp-060 White Oaks are burned could
serve as a reminder that we need to be
Village in protecting the forests of
this world trees are one of our few
sustainable resources but for every one
we cut down or that catches fire it
takes years to regrow a replacement and
perhaps the third and final warning of
the infernal occult skeleton is simply
don't play with matches especially
around trees otherwise you might get
burned we all have that one toy from our
childhood we held near and dear to our
hearts from stuffed bears to action
figures every child has something
meaningful to them that they clung to it
may have been a gift from a parent or
grandparent or maybe it was an old
family Memento passed down from
generation to generation regardless
those of us who have these toys became
extremely connected to them physically
and emotionally perhaps you talked to
this toy like it was your friend or
clung to it during nights where it was
storming in order to comfort yourself
what if these toys were giving the same
feelings back towards us and we didn't
realize it it's a question that only
those in the universe of the SCP
Foundation could find a proper answer to
scp-174
ventriloquists dummy it was a normal day
for scp-174 and its owner Marion
nine-year-old girl had a pretty ordinary
existence for a girl her age a room
decorated in pink and obvious fashion
her school books and art supplies sat on
her little desk in the corner and all of
her dolls and toys neatly sat on the
shelves on the wall she wakes up around
8 o'clock for her third grade classes at
the nearby Elementary School where she
is driven to by her father every day she
gets dressed quickly in her school
uniform
scp-174 remembers a long blue skirt
white button-up shirt and flat black
shoes this was routine
scp-174 watched her every day to the
point it became part of its expected
daily regimen Mary Ventures out of the
room with a quick goodbye to all her
lovely toys as CP 174 being among her
favorites if not her absolute favorite
toy to play with for hours scp-174 would
sit on the shelves of Mary's room
staring at the same pink wall all day
long waiting in pure excitement and
happiness for the room door to get
pushed back open so play time can begin
once again Mary loved the toy and oddly
enough the toy loved Mary back most kids
would probably find scp-174 creepy
ventriloquist's dummies are not often
thought of as cute or cuddly or even
good playtime friends but Mary didn't
care she and scp-174 had so much fun
together that she didn't even comprehend
the fact that it might be creepy never
mind a thought about what other people
might think all the dressing up making
up stories and living them out from
Brave princes saving princesses to evil
dragons or Pirates taking on the seven
seas in search of treasures
scp-174 had fun playing along with
Mary's childhood imagination her Joy was
its Joy it was more than enough for Mary
to be happy and in turn
scp-174 was also happy it remembers the
day it was brought out of the dingy
attic where it was forgotten left to
dust and cobwebs to pile up on it over
time
scp-174 was a creation of Mary's
grandfather a now retired ventriloquist
performer and a master of it at that
scp-174 didn't mind the work but it
wasn't loved like it was now it was just
a prop to be used for laughs and money
but now it was something someone
actually cared about the Glorious
afternoon when Mary discovered him in a
storage bin was a day it wouldn't forget
as it now felt loved and appreciated by
someone Mary didn't want money out of
scp-174 nor did she want fame she just
wanted a friend an scp-174 was going to
give as much as it could to her as Mary
Grew Older it seemed playtime had become
rarer and rarer it went from multiple
times a day to once or maybe twice a
night on a good day to once a week and
now Mary a 16 year old girl didn't look
like she had the time anymore books and
papers piled up on her bed from nights
of studying her attention was grabbed by
her cell phone and late night calls with
her friends and on the weekends when her
and scp-174 would usually spend the most
time together in the past she wasn't
even in the house anymore never mind in
a room and by the time she came back she
was too tired to want to do anything she
didn't talk to it anymore and barely
even looked at it at most scp-174 would
receive a passing glance and a weak
smile but at least she still knew it was
there and that for what it was was
enough for scp-174 to be content two
more years passed and now Mary was 18.
she had grown up so much as cp17
forethought to itself it was a cool day
as the dusk of Summer was upon Mary City
August was coming to a close and Autumn
was steadily creeping up on them but for
some reason Mary hadn't been preparing
for school there was no backpack instead
of a variety of suitcases and bins lined
her room taking up most of the space
that was previously empty clothes
hangers lay on her bed and Mary's mother
was organizing her clothes into two
piles it looked like Mary was moving out
but that wasn't true right she's never
left without her Playmate and her best
friend right after two days of packing
and preparing it seemed Mary was ready
to leave to wherever she was going as
cp-174 hoped it wasn't going to be for
too long perhaps it's a vacation or a
short School field trip had thought but
the fateful day of Mary's departure had
arrived the room was completely cleared
out and other than her pink walls and
floral comforter almost everything was
gone Mary popped back into the room
suitcase and and looked around and left
without a word no goodbye she didn't
even look at scp-174
scp-174 was devastated months passed
without a sign of Mary
scp-174 heard phones ringing and faint
Whispers of her voice through telephone
lines but it wasn't enough
scp-174 missed its friend on one fateful
night
scp-174 was met with rings and alarms
The house's fire alarm system smoke
permeated the air and it began to grow
warmer and warmer than hotter than so
hot it couldn't bear the pain all
scp-174 could do was sit there and wait
for someone something to save it but no
one came
scp-174 woke up wet and charred under a
pile of dirt Ash and wood it could spot
daylight through the cracks and crevices
of the mound that pinned it down it laid
there for what felt like ours before it
heard a familiar voice mom dad the voice
was met with sobering responses hello
sweetie and sorry I had to see this we
don't know what happened it was Mary
back from wherever she went and her
family was here now they could all be
back together scp-17 forethought we have
a few things that survived the fire your
pile is over there Mary's mother said
it's not much but at least it's
something footsteps grew louder towards
scp-174 the pile above it grew lighter
and lighter as the face of its best
friend came clearer and clearer into
view
scp-174 wasn't met with a face of
happiness or joy like it expected more
one of fear and disgust do you see
anything her father asked nothing I want
Mary responded coldly before leaving the
pile all scp-174 wanted was a friend
someone it could care for and would care
for it it tried its best but now it gets
that all meant nothing to marry
scp-174 closed its eye and with a
gut-wrenching feeling of Despair listen
to the voice of its former best friend
slowly fade away it was a few days
months years or even decades before
scp-174 reawoke it wasn't with a new
loving family or in the room of a child
who might play with it again now this
was not where it was it was in a cold
locker with its only light being from
the slits of the locked door that kept
it contained sadness was all that
scp-174 could feel and it's all anyone
around scp-174 could feel its sadness
was so powerful it was influencing those
around it to pity it maybe then they'd
play with it but there is no playing in
what scp-174 would learn to be the SCP
Foundation the SCP Foundation conducted
its standard amount of research on the
anomaly they asked the same questions
they always did what object class do we
give this anomaly initially they gave it
safe it would stay in a box and they
didn't have to watch it plus it it
didn't pose a reasonable amount of
danger but would the SCP Foundation be
correct in its assessment of the object
class
scp-174 was marked as a safe class low
security object up until May 14 2013.
this was a special day for scp-174 well
not exactly for 174 but for Mary it was
Mary's 19th birthday but scp-174 was not
there to wish her that its sadness grew
and grew maybe if it was there for her
she would love it again maybe if it was
there on this day they could play again
just once just one more time they could
be friends again and scp-174 could be
happy again with all its strength as
cp174 moved itself for the first time a
doctor later discovered scp-174 sitting
on the floor next to its containment
unit looking directly at the main
entrance Door the doctor hastily placed
scp-174 back in to its storage locker
and later the foundation would install
surveillance cameras
scp-174 watched the entire process
through the slits in its storage locker
even more discouraging the foundation
also implanted as cp-174 with a tracking
device all hope was lost for scp-174 to
see Mary again but it couldn't forget
her no matter how hard it tried it grew
sadder and sadder to understand
scp-174 better we need to take a look at
the SCP foundation's file on scp-174
scp-174 is a wooden ventriloquist's
dummy with severe damage seen on the
figure as cp-174 has a number of
anomalous properties could it be that
scp-174 sadness and grief over losing
its friend was so great that scp-174
developed these properties it's possible
but the SCP Foundation is still unsure
when viewed in a person's peripheral
vision it has been reported that a
cp-174 will look at them with an
expression of longing or sadness in
general anyone in the vicinity of
scp-174 will grow sad or direct sympathy
at
scp-174 the SCP Foundation later
discovered that anyone who places
scp-174 on their hand feels the urge to
talk to the entity those who have put
scp-174 on their hand will report to
researchers that all scp-174 wants is a
friend that it could talk to those who
wear scp-174 for longer periods of time
will begin speaking in a high-pitched
childlike voice the foundation believes
that this is the voice of scp-174 now
changing the roles of ventriloquist and
ventriloquist dummy as the person
wearing scp-174 is the dummy the subject
will begin to converse with itself
through their own voice and scp-174 in
all cases 174 will tell its wearer that
it was abandoned and left to the trash
by Mary it would tell them how much it
Mary how sad it was and how angry it was
getting
scp-174 learned quickly how easy it
could trick these people into feeling
bad for it it went from telling the
truth about what happened to it to
changing its story over and over again
to the point that the SCP Foundation has
no idea what the true story is and they
have no idea about Mary stories of being
left at a playground to being thrown out
or left on a stage by a performer began
to become commonplace anything
scp-174 could think of it would use to
manipulate the person wearing it
scp-174 knows the truth however but
maybe it's easier for it to lie and
forget the trauma it experienced is it
possible that scp-174 is becoming
corrupted in a way it was also learned
that scp-174's fake stories about its
past will have a direct connection to
the subject that is wearing it so if you
remember a time you might have been
bullied as a child or lost a toy or
anything that might have been something
negative
scp-174 will use that for its own
sympathy the loss of its first owner has
completely changed scp-174's outlook on
life and now it wants to make a friend
by any means necessary even manipulation
through anomalous means scp-174
developed a series of telepathic
abilities to further its manipulation
for sympathy a d-class was ordered to
wear 174. the dolls burned and battered
appearance left the d-class hesitant doc
you sure I have to wear this creepy
thing please proceed with the test
d14285 the doctor responded coldly we
know the foundation is okay with putting
morals aside for their tests so this
answer should have been obvious to the
d-class Personnel
d14285 lifted scp-174 and placed it on
her right hand and a conversation with
the anomaly began what happened to you
d-14285 asked quietly there was a fire
do
14285 said in a high-pitched voice
mimicking scp-174 Highway home we can
perform like they used to own me the
d-class said almost on the verge of
tears
they broke into a house my house and
began to steal anything valuable this
year back in her normal voice D4 14285
responded that that happened to my
family I'm so sorry to hear that you
don't deserve that she said in her
high-pitched voice the burglars they
were stealing everything golden jewelry
money pictures even pieces of art my
owner painted all the memories he made
were being stolen
my father was an artist
d14285 said in her normal voice
burned but I was the only one who lived
the performer who only died trying to
rescue me the d-class says in the voice
of scp-174 he was trying to save me but
but the Flames day
they consumed him now now I have no
fringe anymore
really will you will you be my friend
d14285 breaks down into tears and
returns to her normal voice I'm sorry
she says through sobs I I'm so sorry oh
I'll be your friend the observing
researcher begins to yell cancel the
test immediately there's clearly
something more going on here guards
enter the testing chamber upon the
researchers orders and begin to restrain
d14285 and remove the manipulative
anomaly from her arm the d-class begins
to scream and cry no no no they took it
from me my baby she begins to fight
against the restraining security guards
but is dragged out kicking and screaming
while calling for scp-174 who lays
Motionless in the corner of the testing
chamber it was found that b-class
amnestics were effective in quelling the
lingering effects of scp-174 however if
left untreated those affected by
scp-174's influence and manipulation are
similar in Behavior to those of mothers
separated from their children sadly the
test that led to the discovery of the
nestics being useful and stopping
scp-174's manipulative effects were
found after
d14285's test as she was terminated due
to her not being able to be consoled and
her cries constantly being disruptive
before her termination the foundation
found a number of abnormalities in her
behavior
d-14285 would only ever talk about
scp-174 regardless of topic of
conversation or questions asked to her
she would only respond with the same
frantic line of questions or statements
is the doll okay can I see him what did
you do to him why won't you let me see
him I was supposed to be friends with
him please let me please tell me he's
all right this effect does not persist
as it normally goes away after a few
hours or days but in some cases like
d14285 this effect will endure to the
point of obsession and depression as
such scp-174's object class has been
changed to a Euclid level anomaly the
SCP Foundation deals with anomalies of
varying danger and containment
difficulty we are familiar with ones
that look dangerous and act even more
dangerous from scp-096 the shy guy to
the employees of scp-3008 the infinite
Ikea or even scp-049 the plague doctor
and its Touch of death but what might be
even more dangerous is when the SCP
Foundation discovers an anomaly that
does not look dangerous in the slightest
perhaps that's why they initially placed
an extremely manipulative and dangerous
anomaly into safe class storage the SCP
Foundation is known for its cold tactics
and cruel experiments but in the case of
scp-174 it was extremely important to
test the anomaly in order to know how
dangerous it really was
scp-174 is the story of a toy that was
held near and dear during childhood
similar to the ones we can all
potentially have the play times in
childhood innocence carried those bonds
deeper than we may think in the case of
scp-174 it was used during this period
then pushed aside once its former friend
Mary grew up and had to focus on her
life outside of the world of imagination
this turned scp-174 into a cold monster
who wants that connection and bond back
by any means necessary it puppeteers
people in order to get sympathy
manipulating them by using their own
traumatic stories against them in a sick
twisted attempt to make what it thinks a
friend is if you happen to still have
your favorite childhood toy laying
around somewhere in your house it might
be a good idea to go show it some love
like literally go grab that Tickle Me
Elmo or Hannah Montana singing doll and
give it a hug tell it it's still
appreciated for all the fun times
because while there may be consequences
to your actions or lack thereof the
creature let out an unmistakable squeal
of Rage as stimulus y835 took effect Dr
Christensen pressed his face up against
the glass eager to see the results it
had to work this time it simply had to
he was certain that this attempt would
make all the other failures worth it and
he'd once again prove the foundation's
faith in him to be well placed
scp-5683 shrieked a loud insect-like
sound that would have normally made the
blood run cold of anyone that heard it
but to Dr Christensen it was like music
a monster's dying Fanfare to mark his
success soon he'd be the researcher who
neutralized not one but two tenacious
highly adaptable anomalies the senior
researcher could feel his heart racing
as the deadly giant spider started to
Twitch then burst into two identical
entities the pair of arachnid anomalies
had reacted much like the results of the
tissue sample tests conducted earlier
dividing into two separate organisms
Christensen held his breath the tissue
samples had destroyed each other
attacking and injecting the other with
lethal doses of Venom surely he reasoned
duplicating
scp-5683 into two would have the same
result his heart sank as he watched one
of the spider creatures the duplicate
perish almost immediately as it often
did when presented with human prey
scp-5683 attacked using its mandibles
and impaled its copy with its front legs
to pin it in place the Clone had back
with Dr Christensen already knowing that
would have granted
scp-5683 an immunity to its own Venom
its powers of adaptation were fiercely
frustratingly efficient and nothing
demonstrated this more than the intense
reaction from the man tasked with
destroying it Dr Christensen hurled the
nearest object a coffee mug had a glass
window of the observation room
overlooking the test chamber he pounded
his fist against the glass hardly with
the required Force to cause damage but
enough to send pain shooting down
christensen's wrist which then nestled
in his forearm a reminder that the
experiment like the others had failed
why can't I destroy you he muttered
through clenched teeth looking with
hatred at the enormous spider in the
chamber below the directive had reached
him the day immediately after New Year's
Day 2020 and straight from a member of
the o5 council no less their message
expressed how impressed the council was
with Dr christensen's success with the
Doomsday Clock project and how favorably
his name had been mentioned in Council
meetings this voted well for the
ambitious Foundation doctor he'd been
hoping to snag the director position at
site-04 now that director Bray had
retired but there was one more test from
the o5 council they wanted Dr
Christensen to use the knowledge
garnered during his previous success to
solve the
scp-5683 problem if he could
successfully complete that assignment it
would be his ticket to being promoted
with the comfy role of site director and
all its perks in mind Dr Christensen
accepted the assignment from the council
to deal with
scp-5683
scp-5683 was quite the Beast not an
anomaly for those with intense
Arachnophobia the huge spider-like
organism was extremely hostile towards
humans and had to be kept in a constant
state of medical sedation otherwise it
would relentlessly attempt to breach
containment and Slaughter any and all
Personnel in its path what had made
scp-5683 such a problem for the
foundation was the creature's ability to
rapidly regenerate damage as well as
modify its own body in reaction to
threats much like a certain particularly
hard to destroy reptile The spider-like
Entity could adapt itself to become more
resistant to any danger posed to it and
of course this meant that the foundation
needed this dangerous creature
eradicated the frequent containment
breaches and sheer number of casualties
caused by the arachnid anomaly were
significant enough to cause an
increasing drain on the SCP foundation's
resources so with the termination order
coming from the very top the o5 council
themselves Dr Christensen was tasked
with overseeing the neutralization of
scp-5683 during an initial deliberation
Dr Christensen met with researcher miles
and Hall Junior researcher Silva and
security Chief at a to discuss earlier
attempts to terminate
scp-5683 the new head of the termination
project was perturbed to learn that the
research team had little in the way of
useful information to offer beyond what
the foundation already knew about the
creature but Christensen decided some
basic stress testing would at least be a
start after a successful tissue sample
test wherein some of
scp-5683's genetic material was
incinerated Dr Christensen tried to
Simply destroy the spider with fire an
understandable response to say the least
however exposing scp-5683 to
temperatures of 850 degrees Celsius for
just 30 seconds didn't quite yield the
easy Victory he had hoped for the
arachnid thrashed about and screeched in
reaction to the heat only to rapidly
develop a form of armor plating covering
its entire body the armor was comprised
most of an unknown unidentifiable
substance but it was enough to prevent
scp-5683 from combusting reconvening
with the rest of the team Dr Christensen
hid his pride assuring everyone he was
just trying to establish a baseline
during the previous test of course he
hadn't believed that terminating
scp-5683 with fire would be a success or
so he claimed hiding how much he'd
longed for an easy solution so he could
snatch up the vacant site-04 director
position but to ensure the others
Christensen explained that he'd
requisition some anomalous materials
from the o5 council that they'd be using
in their next termination attempts
nothing that was anomalous enough to
require containment but toxic enough
that they presented a few options for
destroying
scp-5683 uh just for logging purposes
sir may I inquire about the specific
substances we're shipping in junior
researcher Sylvia had asked of course
why 220 y835 and y43 Dr Christensen
quickly recounted them all from memory
I'm told they should be arriving within
the week I expect each would be enough
to do the job but it's best to hedge our
bets this spider doesn't compare to the
lizard I'll tell you that Junior
researcher Silva seemed to take an
interest in what Dr Christensen had just
alluded to his previous work with the
lizard he probed further about it and
Christensen gave a solemn response the
aspiring Foundation doctor recalled an
incident from a few years earlier during
his experimentation with scp-682 some of
the methods Dr Christensen had opted to
employ in an attempt to destroy the hard
to destroy reptile had led to a severe
Containment Breach when describing it he
used the word unpleasant perhaps out of
guilt at how many personnel had lost
their lives due to his actions brushing
the topic aside he assured the team to
get on with testing the new anomalous
stimuli on
scp-5683 stimulus y220 initially showed
some promise during a tissue sample test
it successfully converted part of
scp-5683 into glass which then violently
exploded leaving nothing behind but
attempts to use it to neutralize the
creature itself quickly quash those
promising results within nine seconds of
being exposed to stimulus y220
scp-5683's body rapidly turned to glass
around 80 percent of its arachnid Mass
proceeded to explode shattering in all
directions sending clear shards
showering over the testing chamber as he
watched Dr Christensen allowed himself
to believe that this was mission
accomplished that he'd successfully
terminated
scp-5683 but his celebration was
premature the spider quickly began
reconstituting itself its body
regenerating within the space of 30
seconds after testing with both stimuli
y220 and y835 Dr christensen's
frustration seemed to be increasing with
each failed attempt the newest promotion
was Within Reach and as far as he could
remember he'd done good work with
damaging scp-682 why should eradicating
this anomalous spider be any different
however it was a test with stimulus y436
that enraged the ambitious doctor
expecting the anomalous stimulant to
turn
scp-5683 into a fine Mist Christensen
watched as the creature's body vanished
literally vaporizing changing states of
matter to little more than water in the
air suddenly every light in the facility
powered off plunging the testing chamber
into darkness when the lights came back
on
scp-5683 was standing on all eight legs
right where it had been missed only
three seconds earlier the research team
had gathered for another mediation and
Dr christensen's anger still hadn't
subsided he kicked a chair to emphasize
his frustration alarming Junior
researcher Silva who urged him to calm
down after eventually cooling his temper
Christensen made an announcement that
caused even greater concern to spread
amongst the team I'm requisitioning y910
researcher halls and researcher miles
objected trying to get Dr Christensen to
realize that the course of this action
was excessive Overkill even but
Christensen disregarded them standing by
his latest method for terminating
scp-5683 the global occult Coalition had
previously used y910 to poison Gods he
felt sure that it would work on one
anomalous giant spider his time was
running short Dr Christensen was aware
that any day now the o5 council would be
appointing a replacement director of
site-04 and he wanted that promotion and
he didn't seem to care what Corners he
cut and what risks he took to get there
even if it meant endangering his
research Personnel Dr Christensen
declared that in order to save time it
would be bypassing tissue samples to
test for termination attempts the longer
it took to terminate the anomalous
arachnid the more his window of
opportunity closed and the further the
director position slipped from his
fingertips accepting full responsibility
for The Reckless decision and anything
that might go wrong Dr Christensen
wanted to use stimulus y910 directly on
scp-5683 he urged the research team to
make the necessary preparations unaware
of what his decision would lead to and
the chaos it had already caused the test
was catastrophic so much so that it
caused a Containment Breach but scp-5683
Loose and scuttling about the facility
on its multiple legs Dr Christensen and
Junior researcher Silva were forced to
rush to the secure bunker on site for
safety Christensen was in the state of
panic until he noticed something and not
for the first time either he'd been
detecting a foul smell whenever he'd
conducted the meetings to discuss
termination options but the other
members of the research team had quickly
explained it was nothing more than
repeated accidents in the cafeteria but
here was the stench again worse than
ever yet Junior researcher Silva brushed
it off again stating that
scp-5683 must have gotten into the
facility's reactor the junior researcher
quickly became inconsolable stating that
the whole situation was his fault Dr
Christensen interjected demanding to
know how it was and what Silva had done
to cause this situation he replied that
it was his duty to oppose ill-advised
actions and when Christensen had
declared his intention to use y910 the
Junior researcher hadn't opposed him
Shifting the blame from himself onto his
subordinate Dr Christensen chastised
Silva over how many personnel had died
because of the junior researcher's
refusal to do his job ignoring that it
was christensen's own Ambitions that had
led to the current chaos refusing to be
made a scapegoat Dr Christensen vowed to
pin the full culpability for
scp-5683's Containment Breach onto
Junior researcher Silva saying he'd out
the 05 Council the so-called truth about
what had happened but Silva pointed out
that there wasn't much of a likelihood
that the bunker would survive the
reactor overloading he urged the
ambitious Foundation doctor to admit
some responsibility of his own for what
had happened but Christensen refused
suddenly there came a thunderous banging
at the bunker door a debilitating Pang
of fear struck Dr Christensen causing
him to scream and Retreat from the
entrance yelling no and please as if he
was pleading with the universe itself to
spare him from the spider Junior
researcher Silva walked over to the
bunker door just as strong arachnid legs
tore the heavy steel bulkhead off its
hinges like it was made of little more
than wet paper there was
scp-5683 the enormous spider skittering
Into the Bunker screeching all the while
Silva had put himself between
scp-5683 and the ambitious Foundation
doctor whose hunger for a promotion had
led to all this Carnage the junior race
researcher announced his Noble intention
to sacrifice himself occupying the
creature while urging Christensen to run
the doctor shoved Silva towards the
spider and prepared to run then all of a
sudden
scp-5683 vanished Junior researcher
Silva told Dr Christensen he was
disappointed before researcher miles
researcher Hall and security Chief at a
all entered the bunker through the torn
open hole where the door had been
Christensen questioned where
scp-5683 had gone to which Silva
explained there was little reason to
keep a dummy around once it had served
its purpose as a substitute you
mentioned you worked with the lizard sir
the junior researcher recounted that
there was a Containment Breach if you
don't terribly mind me asking how did
you escape that situation it seemed
quite lethal didn't it afraid and
Confused Dr Christensen asked where he
was Hall and Miles urged him not to ask
questions he already knew the answer to
Silva explained who they all were a jury
specifically Dr christensen's jury and
according to them the ambitious doctor
had disgraced himself again Christensen
had been there for a long time a
considerably long time reliving the same
events over and over again with
scp-5683 acting as a substitute for
scp-682 it was the same situation he'd
made the same decisions the same
mistakes and it had cost lives now Dr
Christensen was trapped in an endless
loop Penance for the casualties that had
occurred at his hands all in the pursuit
of his own selfish personal gain he
asked the jury how long he'd be stuck
there a question Silva responded to with
until you take responsibility sir
immediately Dr Christensen tried to
admit that this all had been his fault
but he didn't mean it not really he
hadn't accepted blame he just wanted a
quick and easy way out of the loop and
the jury of his deceased Personnel knew
it Christensen ran for the door in the
hopes of escaping his fate futile as his
chances were a black iron chain appeared
from around the corner and wrapped
itself around the over-ambitious
doctor's throat ignorant of his pleas
for forgiveness saying he was sorry
wouldn't bring back the people who died
in service of his aspirations to
becoming a site director the chain drag
Dr Christensen through the facility at
such a speed that he collided with every
wall and every corner as he turned
sharply being pulled along the floor but
that and the walls quickly crumbled away
revealing a sight that made Dr
Christensen start screaming that it
wasn't his fault and he never really
stopped What followed involved a great
deal of blood and fire once it was over
it left behind the same awful stench the
doctor had smelled before and he'd soon
be smelling it again too as the cycle
repeated itself the directive had come
straight from a member of the o5 council
they were impressed with Dr Christensen
and the ambitious Foundation doctor had
been hoping to snag a director position
at site-04 but there was one final test
for Dr Christensen to solve the
scp-5683 problem a d-class drag races
through the testing Zone screaming at
the top of his lungs and doing donuts a
mime who was also in the testing chamber
stares with disapproval tapping his foot
impatiently did we mention that the car
is made of spiders yeah this one is
going to be a weird one folks stay tuned
for one of the craziest SCP stories
you've ever heard Emily had always
dreamed of taking a trip to Paris when
the opportunity actually came to visit
the city she was overjoyed she spent her
time exploring art museums tasting the
bread and cheese and walking through the
city streets taking in the sights one of
her favorite things about Paris was all
the street performers as she walked
nibbling on a panel chocolate she
delighted in the antics of jugglers
tossing colorful balls into the air she
gasped at the feet of athleticism and
Grace demonstrated by acrobats and
contortionists she giggled at the Absurd
shows put on by puppeteers and dabbed
tears from her eyes at the sound of
beautiful songs played and sung by
musicians it became part of her daily
routine one night as Emily was walking
back to her hostel after a long language
dinner she found herself walking down
the street she had not encountered
before there was no one around except
for her it was a lovely moment of Peace
but it also struck her as a little bit
eerie and she wished for The Familiar
throngs of people up ahead she spotted
the silhouette of another person and let
out a sigh of relief as she got closer
she could make out the black and white
striped shirt the suspenders the Black
Beret the white face makeup rouged
cheeks and red lips a mime a real
classic French mime she couldn't believe
her luck when he spotted Emily
approaching the Mind began to start a
performance he began with a classic the
invisible box he felt around the walls
of the invisible box looking out with
exaggerated wide eyes and an open mouth
Emily clapped and reached into her bag
for a little bit of money she could use
to tip him after all he was putting on a
performance just for her he deserved it
she walked closer to the mime looking
for a place to put her tip she didn't
see one so she held up her hand offering
the money directly to the mime as he
took notice of how close she was getting
the mime began shaking his head
vigorously eyes wide and insistent she
didn't understand that he was trying to
warn her until it was too late dozens
and dozens of spiders began to crawl
over the mime's face out from inside of
his clothes from his shoes pouring out
over the street and crawling up onto
Emily she tried to brush them off she
tried to run away but no matter how hard
she tried the spiders just kept coming
all she could do was scream in an
attempt to experience a little bit of
live performance Emily unwittingly came
across
scp-3247
scp-3247 is a humanoid entity standing
at approximately 1.7 meters in height it
wears a striped shirt and suspenders
similar to the Garb of a stereotypical
French mime as well as what appears to
be white makeup on its face and all
other Exposed Skin though these aspects
of its appearance seem as if they should
be removable the clothing and makeup are
in fact parts of the entity's physiology
and cannot be removed from its body this
is not the only unusual aspect of the
entity's physical form though it looks
corporeal and solid The Entity cannot
touch or directly interact with any
solid matter with one particular
exception there is a colony of spiders
living on and inside of
scp-3247 these spiders have officially
been designated as
cp-3247-a and are highly protective of
scp-3247 if anyone or anything attempts
to approach
scp-3247 in a threatening manner the
spiders will swarm the Potential Threat
as any Savvy anomalous activity
enthusiasts might have already gathered
these are of course no ordinary spiders
not only do they dwell on and in an
intangible mime but they have a peculiar
response to witnessing a human being
making specific gestures or pantomiming
activities when this occurs the colony
of spiders will form the shape of an
object related to the gestures which
they will then hold for up to three
hours or until given additional stimuli
that prompt a change in shape while the
spider colony is assembled into shape
they will be able to share some of the
given object's functions in spite of
being technically nothing more than a
massive well-coordinated arachnids as
for
scp-3247 it is either incapable of
speech or unwilling to speak instead it
communicates with Foundation staff via
silent liming when it does the spiders
will frequently react to its gestures
becoming effectively living props
scp-3247 does not seem to be especially
thrilled with this likely because miming
is inherently a propless art form and
these spider based props undermine its
artistic Vision otherwise though the
presence of the spiders does not seem to
bother
scp-3247 in order to better understand
the nature of
scp-3247-a foundation staff conducted a
series of tests in each test a d-class
was given a gesture to perform in the
presence of
scp-3247 then the research staff would
record the spider colonies response
during the first test the research staff
ordered d-11424 to attempt to get as
close to
scp-3247 as possible they did not of
course warn him about the spiders he
entered the testing chamber and
approached the mime who was pantomiming
the act of climbing stairs as the Mind
pretended to ascend an invisible
staircase and d-11424 grew closer
instances of
scp-3247-a emerged to take the shape of
a staircase much to the mime's
frustration
scp-3247 stopped its performance
throwing up its hands in a gesture of
defeat the spiders turned their
attention to d11424 and began to swarm
him treating him as a Potential Threat
panicking and Unsure how to communicate
with
scp-3247 while the spiders were
overpowering him
d-11424 began to wave frantically at the
mime the mime simply Shrugged giving him
a look that said well what do you want
me to do about it at this point control
inner intervened instructing d11424 to
pantomime some kind of activity
fortunately before turning to a life of
crime
d11424 had spent several years in a
professional improv troupe and was well
acquainted with pantomime his performing
instincts kicked in and he leapt into
action he put a hand to his ear as if
listening to the ringing of a telephone
the spiders stopped their attack
responding immediately to his cue they
formed into the shape of a small table
with an old-fashioned rotary phone on
top the mime rolled its eyes into
disdain at the side of this prop based
performance but d11424 was on a roll he
crossed to the phone picked up the
receiver and held it to his ear hello he
asked out of habit he wasn't expecting
to hear a voice on the other line but
then he did or rather he heard the
approximation of a human voice created
by a swarm of anomalous spiders it
sounded a bit like a human voice sped up
high-pitched and squeaky speaking some
sort of gibberish realizing that the
this was his moment to escape
d-11424 placed the phone back in place
and promptly left the testing chamber
the spiders remained in the shape of the
rotary phone and the table for the next
two hours at which point they
disassembled and returned to their home
on
scp-3247 after his surprisingly creative
work in this first test it was decided
that d11424 would be the designated test
subject for all future testing with
scp-3247 provided that additional
complications did not arise though he
wasn't especially fond of spiders
d11424 was more than happy to accept the
assignment not that he had much choice
in the matter still it was definitely a
better deal than getting fed to scp-682
and it was a nice excuse to use his
improv skills again after a long
retirement during the second test d11424
knew what to expect from
scp-3247 for this test he was told to
pantomime playing tug of war with an
invisible opponent and an invisible rope
now that he knew his improvisational
scene partner would be a colony of
spiders he was able to enter the testing
chamber with confidence once inside he
began to pantomime pulling on a rope
having that rope tugged away from him by
a strong opponent and struggling to pull
back the spiders reacted right away
arranging themselves into the shapes of
a long rope one side of which was in
d11424's hands as well as a large
humanoid vaguely muscular in shape that
was holding the other side of the Rope
the spiders gave the Rope a sharp tug
causing d-11424 to lose his balance and
fall over the Rope slipping out of his
grasp aside from some injury to his
pride he was otherwise unharmed during
test number three
d-11424 was instructed to enter the
testing chamber and close his fist while
extending the thumb and index finger in
a gesture colloquially known as finger
guns sure enough as soon as he assumed
this position the spiders assembled into
the shape of a handgun
d11424 was then instructed to pick up
the spider gun and squeeze the place
where the trigger would be if it was a
real gun and not you know spiders a loud
cracking sound was heard when the
d-class squeezed as a spider shot out of
the barrel of the gun at high speed
before smacking into the nearby wall
leaving a small hole in the surface
d11424 fired several more times each
Shot firing an individual spider at a
pace that attending researchers
described as faster than a speeding
bullet after firing six rounds of
spiders at the wall
d-11424 was instructed to place the
spider gun back on the ground during
test number 76
d11424 was ordered to hold his hands
together and wiggle four fingers on each
hand effectively pantomiming a spider
the research team was curious to see
what the spiders would do when presented
with a shape that matched their usual
unassembled form
scp-3247 who generally did not react
much to the experiments on its spider
began shaking its head in mild
disappointment as approximately
640 spiders emerged from its body
dividing themselves into groups of eight
each group of eight spiders then joined
to form one large spider leaving eight
spiders these eight then split into
pairs who joined together into one
larger spider and so on and so forth
until there was one single giant spider
made from the hundreds of smaller
spiders at this point d11424 followed
his heart jumping onto the mega spider's
back and riding it like a bull at the
rodeo as the spider bucked and ran back
and forth across the room according to
official transcripts d-11424 yelled ye
ha throughout this part of the test
until the head researcher ordered him to
climb down from the spider and exit the
room he was reprimanded for his behavior
and warned that if he acted without
approval again he would be taken off the
project and reassigned to a much less
enjoyable position as one of the
designated eyes on SCP-173
d-11424 immediately agreed to comply
with future instructions during test
number 133
d-11424 was sent into the testing
chamber and told to Shadowbox he danced
back and forth across the cell doing his
best Sylvester Stallone impression and
throwing punches in the general
direction of the spiders in response
approximately 3 000 spiders poured out
of
scp-3247 assembling into the shadowy
shape of a boxer and began to attack
d11424 the mass of spiders conducted
itself at the level of a professional
boxer dodging d1142 Force hits before
coming back at him with a jab cross lead
uppercut and rear uppercut before he
could defend himself
d11424 fell to the ground unconscious
and guards were forced to interrupt the
test in order to remove him from the
room and take him to the infirmary for
medical treatment after taking some time
to recuperate
d11424 returned to testing with
scp-3247-a it was instructed to mime
steering a wheel such as that of a car
immediately a number of spiders
previously unseen during testing emerged
from
scp-3247 arranging themselves into the
shape of a sedan
d-11424 was then commanded to climb
inside of the spider car and see if he
could start it he refused insisting I'm
not getting in a spider car are you nuts
when pressed by control to comply with
orders he made a rude hand gesture I'll
let you guess what that was the spiders
began to scramble to reassemble
themselves in response to the changed
gesture prompting control to stop the
test early to spare the researchers
sensibilities with strict guidelines to
avoid inappropriate or by violent
gestures d11424 was sent back into the
testing chamber with instruction to try
out a variety of animal inspired
gestures in Rapid succession he formed
one hand into a fist and made a peace
sign with the other hand putting them
together to make a snail as he made his
hand snail crawl through the air the
spiders crawled onto the floor and
assembled into the shape of a snail in
front of d-11424 though the spiders
moved quickly at their usual scuttling
Pace once they formed into the snail
they slowed to a gradual creep d11424
noted a shiny slimy Trail left behind on
the floor as the spider snail moved he
was asked to consider touching it but
refused simply stating ew no next he
took his hands and formed the shape of a
wolf's head howling at the moon the
research staff were curious to see if
the spiders would form a wolf's head or
the animal's entire body they got their
answer as the spider swarmed and shifted
forming the shape of a full-sized gray
wolf the wolf padded back and forth
across the room before sitting down
lifting its head and emitting an audible
howl that sounded almost
indistinguishable from the real thing
next d11424 crossed his thumbs over each
other fluttering hands like a pair of
wings the spider separated into smaller
groups and came together to form
butterflies similar in size to a monarch
these spider butterflies began to flap
their wings and much to d11424 surprise
they took flight and swirled through the
air around him the d-class was so moved
by the beautiful sight that he shed a
single tear which he promptly wiped away
out of embarrassment control then
prompted him to try the next animal
gesture d-11424 used his hands to form
the shape of a rabbit several of the
spiders crawled away returning to
scp-3247 and the remaining spiders took
on the form of a rabbit the spider
rabbit hopped realistically around the
room twitching its ears and tail at this
point d11424 was instructed to offer the
spa spider rabbit a carrot he produced a
carrot from his pocket holding it out in
front of him the spider rabbit hopped
over to him and one Crunch at a time
began to eat the carrot until none
remained d-11424 appeared shaken up and
asked to leave the testing chamber as he
followed all of his instructions this
request was granted when he exited the
chamber all he would say was where the
hell did the carrot go it doesn't have a
stomach it doesn't have a mouth where
did it go
scp-3247 is kept in an isolated chamber
located in the arachnid wing of area 12.
it does not appear to require food or
rest but it has been provided with a
television and a collection of silent
films for morale purposes instances of
scp-3247-a are fed via a fully automated
system that dispenses 20 grams of live
crickets every week should a Containment
Breach occur staff have been instructed
to find a way to make escaped spiders
take on the shape that renders them
motionless then simply pick the spider
class stir up and place it back inside
of the cell it is unlikely that the
foundation will ever get an explanation
for where the intangible mime and his
merry band of spider performers
originated from but one thing is clear
they won't be performing in public again
anytime soon the Shinobi crouched low on
the Pagoda roof and listened to the
night air up here in the mountains away
from the hustle and bustle of the
markets in town it was almost silent
just the distant rattle of shutters
somewhere behind him the mountain Shrine
was tucked out of sight so far into the
countryside that no one would stumble
onto it by accident no one would come
here without a reason the Shinobi knew
the face of his Target a warlord turned
politician with more blood on his hands
than the Assassin sent to kill him by
the burning glow of the night sky the
Shinobi could see the man kneeling at
The Shrine the path was made up of small
stones so he'd have to draw drop onto
the grass and creep around the pond to
approach his Target no guards no one
else was there at all this was the spot
where the man came to pray when he was
struggling to sleep perhaps trying to
atone for the lives he'd taken perhaps
he didn't care at all the ninja drew the
blade in total silence and time just
dropped to the ground with the rattling
noise in the distance with each dainty
step he closed the distance to his
Target readying the blade over his head
it was done in a moment the man was dead
before his body hit the ground he likely
didn't even notice as the steel had
severed the nerves running down his
spinal cord so Shard was the blade that
had slid through his bones like a fish
through water raising the blade to his
eyes the Shinobi cleaned it quickly if
he was seen with blood on his sword he
would immediately be implicated not that
he was ever seen But precautions like
this were what kept him out of sight for
all these years when you lived in The
Valley Of Ashes the burial grounds for
countless Wars you had to become a
shadow become one of the ancient Spirits
haunting the woods but as he wiped the
red from the steel he caught a flash of
light in the reflection an orange glow
marking a jagged line across the metal
that's strange Sunset was several hours
ago come to think of it why was there an
orange glow in the sky he snapped his
neck around to see the fires through the
gates into the pagoda's garden down by
the Ocean's Edge at the foot of the
mountains was the city where he had
always lived and it was on fire leaping
up onto the walls he stood up straight
surveying the horror scene taking place
before him thick plumes of smoke
billowed up into the night sky so dense
and large that it seemed to become the
Blackness of the night it was hard to
make out much of what was going on down
there the Shinobi looked everywhere to
try to see the invading army or for the
rioters but there were none just people
running in all directions like ants out
of a flooding Nest but there moving in
amongst the smoke were other shapes
impossibly tall lumbering around like
people people that towered over the
houses that had to Crane down to the
ground to scoop up the poor civilians
who were running this way and that the
Shinobi stood there terrified as he
realized the rattling sound he'd been
hearing all night wasn't from any
shutters at all he could do nothing but
watch as the trees in front of him
trembled and buckled in all directions
as a hulking shadowy figure lumbered
towards him the Imperial Japanese
anomalous matters examination agency or
the ija mea was a Japanese agency
responsible for tracking a number of
mysterious and often dangerous artifacts
creatures and anomalies prior to the
second world war in 1945 the ijamea was
shut down and absorbed into the SCP
Foundation all of these data historic
records and anomalies were all
transferred over into the foundation's
control reasons for this were partially
political and partially in the interest
of world peace the formation of the
ijmea was influenced heavily by Japan's
ties with Germany in the first half of
the 20th century the Imperial German
anomalous matters examination agency was
the blueprint for their Japanese
equivalent however with increasing
militarism in Japan throughout the 20th
century the ijmea became increasingly
obsessed with trying to harness their
anomalous discoveries in the interests
of military power their goal became the
establishment of a Yokai Battalion
powerful enough to establish them as one
of if not the world's greatest
superpower following the bombings of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki Japan surrendered
in the second world war and agreed to
dissolve its military including the ija
mea that left the foundation with the
task of picking up the threads left
behind and trying to come up with new
ways of securing containing and
protecting some of Japan's most
deadliest scps few more deadly and
evasive than the entities that were too
much even for the Yokai Battalion
scp-2863 in 1946 cleanup operations were
in full effect trying to deal with the
Fallout from the atomic bomb dropped on
Nagasaki Crews dressed in bloodline
suits worked Around the Clock burying
radioactive material and trying to
remove as much contaminated debris as
possible rebuilding this city was still
a long way off at various points the
wind would kick up and carry the dust
Left Behind into the air creating a
dangerous radioactive Haze Crews
continued to work through such
conditions as the understanding of
Airborne contamination was still in its
infancy Watanabe Goro was one such
worker Midway through a night shift and
clasping a damp rag to his mouth he
pushed on through the dust clearing out
bill building after building they had
spent the morning carrying corpses out
of an unidentifiable building the
corpses themselves were pretty much worn
away too just skeletons really charred
by the blast from months before as Goro
staggered along the street he kept
feeling like he was imagining things the
long hours and traumatic conditions were
enough to make him see all kinds of
things in his dreams but he kept feeling
like his dreams were starting to creep
into the real world Shadows kept moving
through the haze all around him taller
than buildings staggering around as if
they were drunk they had been appearing
all night just out of sight but always
close by he stopped and leaned against
what was left of a brick wall there was
one of his hallucinations now just up
ahead of him the husks of buildings on
either side of him were about as tall as
their knees it must have been 30 meters
tall at least but its legs were strange
there seemed to be a gap in the middle
of each of them they were skinny no
skeletal the skeleton's foot crushed a
car right in front of him the crunch of
metal was loud enough to snap Goro out
of his stupor this wasn't a
hallucination hallucinations can't crush
cars with a LP tumbled backwards staring
up into the haze of dust he saw the
shape of a pelvis above it what must
have been a rib cage the size of his
house but the creature disappeared into
the darkness and the dust if it was too
tall for him to see its face maybe it
was too tall to see him on the ground as
well the skeleton stopped standing
directly over him for a second he
thought that maybe he'd be okay but then
with a great rattling Rumble the monster
hunched down low and the enormous skull
appeared out of the haze flying right
towards him he managed to dodge its
gnashing teeth but it caught his foot
sending him rolling through the
radioactive dirt Goro didn't give
himself a moment to recover though he
took off running as fast as he could
hearing the rattling sound terrifyingly
closed captioning not available
Sunset and will lose all Corporal
reality when exposed to sunlight in the
morning or any light source over 1.1 Lux
to give you some reference for that
Moonlight typically Falls between 0.25
and 1 Lux a typical room with the light
on will be 100 or even 1 000 times
brighter as you can imagine this has
made them virtually impossible to
contain as they manifest an unmanifest
outside of controllable conditions they
seem to have continuous existence in
some way however as previously
neutralized instances can and will
reappear later on in folklore the gasha
docuro are spirits that take control of
skeletons some hesitant researchers have
posited that perhaps the instances that
dematerialize are returning to their
Spirit form little is understood about
what that means in practice what's more
this SCP cannot be photographed all
attempts to capture them on film or
digital cameras have failed including
video tests it is theorized that there
is a link between them not appearing on
camera and their disappearance when
exposed to light again the link between
them is still mostly unknown due to a
steady increase in urban development in
Japan and ongoing peace in the region
appearances of this SCP are growing
increasingly rare while this marks a
positive change for the people of Japan
it makes it even more difficult to study
this SCP and learn how to prevent it in
the future the most recent fatality to
occur at the Bony hands of
scp-2863 happened in 2008 and it was
part of a foundation experiment While
most of Hiroshima and Nagasaki had been
redeveloped into bustling metropolitan
areas the outskirts of each City
particularly several Parks saw
occasional instances of
scp-2863 appearing at night as such the
SCP Foundation conducted a series of
experiments under cover of Nightfall
releasing d-class Personnel into a park
in Hiroshima to observe how the scps
hunted humans their enormous height
towering at over 30 meters gave them a
huge Advantage being able to chase
people down with little difficulty
another notable thing about them is just
how quietly they move there is a gentle
rattling sound that follows them around
but aside from that they are very
light-footed and difficult to detect
until they are right on top of you this
isn't helped by the fact that they hunt
at night as a result they are remarkably
quick at catching their prey once they
have snatched their victims up in their
skeletal fingers they perform the same
eating ritual every time they eat the
person and consume their blood initially
confused by this finding the foundation
was unsure where the blood was going as
the skeletons had no obvious digestive
system after the release of several more
d-class Personnel into the park they
still weren't certain but they believed
that the SCP instances were absorbing
the blood into their bones in some way
further testing was requested but denied
due to the sheer number of d-class
fatalities in the area they were
starting to run out and would have to
ship more of them across to Japan which
was just a bit inconvenient for everyone
involved as the outskirts of those
cities have been urbanized the instances
of scp-2863 have reduced to the point
that a smaller contingent of agents and
researchers are now left in place the
light pollution from these areas is
enough to prevent them from being able
to manifest in the first place for the
most part only on the rare occasion of
power outages have mobile task force
zero three been deployed whilst
researching this SCP the foundation came
across an account from a Shinobi in the
1700s it was rare to find any kind of
written document from a ninja for
obvious reasons but the account
discovered painted a harrowing picture
of just how much damage these Yokai
could inflict upon a city the nameless
Shinobi first encountered
scp-2863 while assassinating an unnamed
Target in the mountains above his
fishing Town looking down on the fires
below him he saw human shapes walking
through the smoke dwarfing the buildings
they moved between before an instance
charged through the trees straight at
him diving out of the way the Shinobi
quickly melted into the Shadows both man
and Demon hunted one another throughout
the night he managed to climb onto its
spine and inflict what he was certain
would be a killing blow to the skeleton
only for his blade to bounce right off
the bone caught and vulnerable for the
first time in his life the Shinobi was
helpless as the spirit threw him from
its back into the courtyard and charged
at him it was only the Hem of the Ninja
sleeve Catching Fire from a candle that
saved him just as the skeleton was about
to bite down on his head the light
flared and the SCP disappeared entirely
for a long while the man lay in the
courtyard pondering his actions he
should have died that night yet he
survived getting slowly to his feet the
man now knew what his Destiny was a
monster that strikes from the Shadows
scared of
were not so different understanding his
Target was the first step to defeating
them snatching up a lantern from the
ground the Shinobi descended the
mountain into the wreckage of his
hometown and defended his people by
night he would emerge hunting down the
gasha dokaru under the cover of Darkness
banishing them with the light hidden
under a dark sheet the man fought night
after night narrowly risking death to
save his people from the onslaught of
the evil spirit a small plaque was
installed by the ija mea shortly before
the foundation took over the management
of the SCP it was installed at the foot
of an old Pagoda just outside a small
fishing Village on it was a simple Haiku
walking in Shadow in the midst of our
demons we will find the light now check
out
scp-2662 Cthulhu and scp-2935 o death
for more